videos
good morning everybody
um here we are in the uh February the
6th it's warmer outside so we can all be
favorable but you know unfortunately in
the other side of the world
um a horrific earthquake occurred
yesterday in Turkey in the Southeastern
portion of the country on the Syrian
border and I I've been in that area and
also all through the the uh west coast
of turkey and
the area that got hurt hurt was the
Kurdish area and the area in Syria as
well and we're talking earthquake that's
approaching seven point what six nine
somewhere in that neighborhood that
those are real shakers I've been in
earthquakes up in Alaska a number of
times but they only got to the magnitude
of 5 point plus and that's when the
dishes were flying off the the shelves
and the whole floor was rolling in our
house because we had radiant heat in a
cement slab and house was just like uh
like this and so I Penny the people over
there because the buildings which they
built have not been up to code
especially in that area of of the worlds
and they have well over a thousand that
they know are dead right now and well
over you know thousands which are
injured and and to top it off they're
going through some of that horrific cold
weather right now that we experienced so
our thoughts should be with them today
the issues which we're going to be
dealing with are going to see minor
compared to what's going on over there
so going on
I'd like to rec recognize those which
are the substitutes on committee day we
have one person can't be here that or it
will be here in about 15 minutes traffic
jam evidently is awful where where's the
traffic jam located uh I'm not sure oh
she's coming from Bedford so I'm not
sure how exactly where okay so I'd like
to recognize Larry Gagnon who's here
today gagne gagne
Cagney
um I think Larry came on when I came on
years ago so
yep that's it oh wait
well
shouldn't have listened huh
okay so going on with today's uh a
docket uh just a couple announcements uh
I've got a good return on the committee
reports and I really appreciate that got
everything in on the exact sessions for
2-1 February 1. I'm still looking for
some that came out on February the 3rd
however it's we're really getting the
job done here I need to have all those
that are for the third of February into
me uh by the closest close of uh I was
going to say close the school today but
by the close of our our dealing today
here
and
um then other announcements we we do
have some bills which uh we may jump
over today and that will guarantee us uh
early bills uh which we need a little
bit more discussion one is the funding
issue dealing with how we fund education
um there are there are several policy
issues that need to be resolved I think
we're really getting working this out
but chances are we won't act on those
until the February 13th and I hate to
say if we absolutely need uh February
15th that's the of course in the 14th
you know we have the governor speaking
and we do have a session and then the
the 15th is the uh last day Wednesday
that we we can do it through on the 16th
but that won't to get early bills out so
we may need if we don't do it on the
13th there's also by the end of the day
I'm going to have some subcommittees
together on some of the the bills which
we've had 170 168 267 and 654.
those bills are ones which we have
recessed or indicated that we need
subcommittee work before we're going to
move forward they are not early bills so
we have to March 16th to work on that
so are there any other announcements
from members of the committee if not
we're just going to wait a little bit
until the traffic jam lightens up
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair I would just update
you on the situation over in the mid
East there they did experience another
almost magnitude 8.0 earthquake about 6
it's very serious and of course turkey
as you know has you know issues within
that country political issues and this
is one of the areas of the country which
is
um having difficulty
so and the airports have been wiped out
in fact they the runways in Istanbul
which is that's a huge airport if you've
been there flown in there three times
and half the runways are out of
commission
um so so
alrighty so let's just um we can get in
and open up our discussion and start
moving on some of the bills because we
do have a very heavy load today
um so I'm gonna jump over some bills and
jump down to something which we may be
able to you know
move forward on
relative to water bottle filling
stations in schools
the bill which uh
um I I presented that bill earlier it's
one where we're trying to uh
okay this repeals the need for that
rule-making authority to adopt the rules
pursuant to this this the needs of this
uh bill
statutory language already States just
like we did on the
um
issues associated with the fourth year
we embedded mathematics into the
curriculum at the at the high school so
statutory language expressed exactly how
it was done they did not need to make
rules they just took the statutory
language and made that the rule the same
thing right here with the water bottle
filling stations they want to make the
stat story language the rule so we don't
have to go through another six to
what eight months of rule making with
gel car and that takes a while so
any further discussion on this before we
have a motion to move on that
if not I'm going to call on repson
McDonald
I move that we find The Spill ought to
pass
is there a second second perhaps in four
seconds ought to pass on
now clerk you got your stuff together
there
great thank you so the bill is uh
dealing with relative to water bottle
filling stations in schools
bill number is 466 and the motion is OTP
Madam clerk would you please call the
roll
nice Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative gagne
representative McDonnell yes represent
representative Noble not here uh
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison
representative Woodcock yeah
representative Heath yes representative
balbooni yes representative cascabin yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes
19 years everybody good ones
representative gagne you're going to
have fun sitting the side rep some
Woodcock over there he has a a
principal's voice and he uses it
okay the next bill which we're going to
uh address is
um
the bill right below at hb501
this is ages for special education
services
501.
a recognized representative Lexus for
our motion
I'd like to move OTP
I'll second represent Belcher II said
motion B made by
uh represent lekka second by
representative Belcher this bill is
relative to the ages for special
education services uh represent electus
you're recognized as the maker of the
motion
yes uh Federal uh says
um
that special education services shall be
provided five
through 21 inclusive meaning all of the
age of 21 and some of our laws were
until 21 and we passed last year a law
to make it
um
trying to make it consistent all across
the board for us making it 21 inclusive
but this little piece of law got missed
and so this is just a cleanup Bill to
say oops we missed fixing it here and
it's just to fix it in the places we
Nest that's it further discussion
represent Belcher
not seeing any uh
we have a motion on the floor is ought
to pass on 501 this is relative to ages
for special education services age 21
inclusive
metal Clerk
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative gagne
yes representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal
yes representative cortielo yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Ellison yes representative yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman left yes
I'll write the next bill which we're
going to take is the first one that's
listed on our docket for today that's HP
521 this is an early Bill relative to
the Department of Education payment for
represent cordelli you're recognized for
a motion uh thank you Mr chairman I
would like to move occupass on House
Bill 521
is there a second
second representative Fort seconds the
motion uh representative cordelli uh
thank you
um I believe that
um
this uh Bill uh properly defines uh the
costs and who will be responsible for
costs
um when there is uh a required placement
um it outlines that
Health and Human Services is responsible
if the student placed is not special
needs or the placement is not due to a
special needs situation
doe is responsible if it is a special
needs student or if the placement is due
to special needs so I think that that's
needed Clarity in terms of the payment
responsibilities
further discussion representative miler
thank you Mr chair it's my understanding
according to my notes that this was a
doe requested bill is that correct
the other others have that in their
yeah it actually says it on the
um
okay did we ever get an updated fiscal
because you know Finance is going to
have to get that then uh if we're we got
to get it out of committee
um represent Tanner
I forget what a means uh in the in the
title The FN Dash a could you explain
that to me please
probably
perhaps rep Heath does
[Laughter]
maybe amended
521 fiscal note I thought it was
appropriation
yeah yeah I think yeah this makes makes
sense
and where we don't know what the
appropriation is or needed that's going
to be fiscal's responsibility to get on
that that's most likely why this is
going as an early build
they need to get it to the second
committee
representative cascadden I have a
question regarding this bill
um
is it only to pay the educational
component
of an episode of treatment
um
or is it the full residential cost and
treatment and
medical and physical and mental
well I I think I'll answer that one on
page three where you'll see the
highlighted language it says any caught
on lines two three four five yep any
cost of special education or special
education related Services related to an
episode of treatment and determination
of placement by the Department of Health
and Human Services shall be covered in
full for students with disabilities by
the Department of Education I.E so
they're talking about education or
special education which is academics you
know we've gone through this with
Medicaid to schools okay
um where HHS was involved with that and
is involved that's where the money flows
through so by the wording of that I see
that yes doe will be responsible for
paying the education the academic stuff
in the IEP
follow-up yes
um
I'm sorry I just wiped it out
so does this Trump VIP team
meeting or decision
or does it just reference the state will
pay for the educational component of any
student inclusive of special ed student
in that treatment facility
[Applause]
and is it educational
component or
I don't know my experiences that usually
the schools and the parents work in
Tandem and a parent who doesn't want to
know doesn't want anybody involved
usually takes care of it with their
insurance or however they do DHHS so I'm
just trying to get clarity on that
um
it says the doe is going to pay
but
uh it's not clear to me is it when a
student goes to an episode
and a parent places them say at
Hampstead
the school is a technical question uh
Becky you're you've been a director of
special ed
picking on you
just going by experience sorry well I've
been there too and yeah IEP we've had
kids go up to the hospital for a
neurological correct you know and we
ended up carrying that Freight too but
that was years ago right thanks good
morning for the record uh Becky Wilson
for the New Hampshire school boards
Association but previously served as a
special ed director here for about 20
years
I don't know representative if you want
to repeat the question I'll try to
answer the question
um
excuse me
so the amendment includes any cost of
special ed or related Services related
to an episode of treatment in the
determination of placement by the
Department of Health and Human Services
shall be covered in full for students
with disabilities by the department of
Ed
is that in reference of students who are
not in public school
because it's my understanding that the
educational component
and special ed services usually a
district
tries to make sure that they either pay
for those to occur or provide them
so I'm not sure who this is addressing
and I'm concerned does this address the
IEP team because I mean it's I can't
imagine that if a parent has to
you know bring a child to Hampstead
Hospital
and whether they're identified or not
that a school team immediately meets
and to get Services maybe that child is
immediately identified OHI
or already has a disability
so just trying to get some some detail
on what the intent is here and who does
it cover that is not already covered
thank you for the question does that
make sense I think so so I'll try to
give a brief synopsis of I think where
what this bill is trying to address
there there are students who for
whatever reason are placed outside of
the IEP team process to your point
perhaps there's challenges outside of
school the child needs immediate
placement somewhere or DHHS is involved
and they are the placing agency not the
school district those placements
occasionally and more often recently
have been happening at a higher rate and
the IEP team is not part of those
decisions so the student might be in
school one day the next overnight
something happens the student is placed
either by the parent or by DHHS the
challenge is exactly what you're saying
which is that the IEP team has not is
not making that placement they're not
saying at school the child requires a
residential placement somewhere the
student is successful or at least able
to be addressed at school again they're
getting their faith at school but
because the child is placed Now by an
agency outside of the IEP team what has
been happening is that the school
district is on the hook so to speak for
the educational placement cost even
though they had no
part in making that decision and it
doesn't matter whether the team agrees
with or not I mean for the people are
making the decision that's right for the
student in that moment but it's not
really School related
this bill is just saying that above the
three times the amount the school
district is still paying for the
educational placement up to the three
times the per pupil cost it's only above
the three times just like the special ed
Aid that the Department of Education is
going to pay the difference because
what's been happening I believe to this
point and you would get a different
answer potentially or at least a more
concise answer from maybe somebody at
NHA sea is that the the district is
housing all the cost regardless of once
it hits sort of the cadied cap the
district has been on the hook regardless
because they don't have any control of
that placement but it's not necessarily
something that they've budgeted for so
this just says that
beyond the three times the per people
cost the department of Ed is going to
pay the difference regardless of how far
out that goes and it's I don't believe
it's at 80 I believe it's at a full 100
percent
thank you I just want to make sure that
follow sorry yeah so follow-up that yeah
the last part kind of got me a little
bit
when you said that once we get beyond
the three and a half
the the locals on the hook for 20 and 80
percent the state you were just saying
that the local would not be on the hook
for this that now with this language
right here
um
it doesn't it would be by the Department
of Education is that wiping out the
catastrophic Aid
thank you for the question the way that
I read this if you start on line 34 on
page two
it says you know any cost beyond the
three times Etc shall be the liability
of the Department of Ed and then as you
go on to page three it says any cost of
the special ed or special ed and related
services
part of the episode of treatment
shall be covered in full for students
with disabilities by the Department of
Education
foreign
thank you if you go just a little
further on page three line six through
eight it says the Department of Health
and Human Services is liable for all
court ordered and episode of treatment
costs other than special ed or special
ed and regulated services
so I read that to clarify what Dr Garden
represented was asking about
um and in the original discussion
I believe it was Rebecca Fredette who
said
that the intent is to get these students
into the treatment they need avoiding
the lengthy process of court-ordered
placement which would be paid for but
is there a further discussion from the
committee represent Myler yeah my notes
indicate that all of this outside the
idea
and that
um that and it's beyond the IEP so it
seemed to me that this would be uh
clearly issues
around Behavior suicide potential
Etc that that's what this is really
really addressing not the inside
educational piece of it
okay does the is the committee at the
point where we're ready to act on this
bill no further discussion needed
that representative thank you realize
the question that
um I'm looking back at uh Becky Curtis
dialogue so just so I'm clear on this
currently if a student is placed in a
non-ip placement emergency instead of
cancer hospital at Dr Scott brought up
um the school district is responsible
for only the Special Egg costs and DHHS
picks up the other costs associated with
the placement
and how is this going to change that I
didn't see the I hear what Becky said
about 100 I don't see that I do see what
they're talking about the 678 so I'm
really I'm just a little bit uh unclear
on the distribution or responsibility of
funding uh beyond the iee placement IEP
placement
unfortunately I wasn't here for that
hearing I was out okay in another area
so I I wasn't able to act you know
answer that is there anybody here that
could help out with that
I'm not sure if I quite understand the
the question
um
but I'm just trying to figure out how
this differs in terms of distribution of
funding uh with the bill change than it
does
currently
spec is somebody out there yes
good morning members of the committee
could you introduce yourself please for
the record my name is Rebecca Ross I'm
the director of children's Behavioral
Health at the Department of Health and
Human Services good help us I am happy
to help answer any questions although I
was not part of putting this bill
together
um
by the way brief history prior to a
couple years ago in order for a child to
access residential treatment and not
Hampstead Hospital acute psychiatric
care but residential behavioral health
treatment they could only access that
through either the juvenile justice
system or the child protection system
which required a court order for
placement
previously this statute was amended
um
to provide for the payment of the
educational services for those children
who were court-ordered into placement
through Child Protection or Juvenile
Justice
through part of the system of care and
the residential transformation we've
worked within the department to create
Pathways to access the behavioral health
treatment that children and youth need
without the trauma and need for court to
allow families to get the services that
they need earlier with shorter lengths
of stay to return home to the community
and to their schools faster without that
Court involvement so over the last
couple years we have started providing
that access to Residential Treatment
following a clinical assessment directly
through the behavior The Bureau for
children's Behavioral Health these are
the cases that we're talking about the
intent of this provision my
understanding was to match that of what
already existed for child protection and
JJ cases where
um the school would cover the cost of
the education for the child that needed
that placement and was unable to stay in
their their home
um while HHS picked up both the clinical
costs for the the mental health and
Behavioral Health Services as well as
The Boarding care during that period of
time and this would just be matching
that otherwise we're going to be moving
in a backward Direction where children
and families are forced to go to court
to access those Services
rather than getting them directly when
needed
happy to answer any other questions
representative Miler thank you for being
here and clarifying this so what you're
really saying is that what this bill
does it really matches the practice
that's taking place currently correct
yeah yes and I think it provides some
clarity that when it's a voluntary
placement through the department so
we've vetted the clinical need for it we
have vetted that it's the appropriate
placement it's going through one of our
certified providers and we've approved
funding
um then it matches what already happens
for those court involved cases this is
not if parents are choosing to remove
their children and go to an alternative
school or a boarding school this is for
those clinical Residential Treatment
episodes
um but that no longer require Court
approval
everybody got it represent cascaden
um just to be sure they would St talking
about non-special ed kids in a
residential treatment school district
will continue to provide the educational
component
without going it through the systems of
care are fast I think that
can happen a lot of different ways I
think that's still something that we
need to work to problem solve through
um how how that's happening and and how
those decisions are made jointly
certainly the intent of the system of
care is that those decisions are made
through an entire team that supports
that decision but I think that there are
differences throughout the state how
that that's the confusing part for me
that uh for example there is a student
and I've given this example before that
resides in Plymouth New Hampshire
and has been placed in the correctional
facility in Haverhill New Hampshire
and was sent there via doing something
wrong in Hanover
and has now also receiving treatment
like this at Cottage Hospital in
Haverhill so the true student had that
person has an IEP
so it's my understanding that the
academic portion
that that student's going to receive
while at Cottage Hospital
for this episode of treatment is the
the resident District
so this is far beyond me once you start
to engage the correctional system
um they are no longer my clients I'm no
longer the Attorney General's office I I
can't speak to that because that's
lately we have somebody standing up in
even responsible for organizing how
those services are going to be delivered
to that studio under the hospital
setting hospitals offer all different
kinds of programming depending on what
hospital you are at and what the
purposes of your hospitalization the
district that's responsible for the IEP
will be responsible for figuring out
that perils exactly what I was saying
it's okay are there further questions
Madam clerk would you please call the
rule
this is on 521 relative to the
Department of Education payment for
placement for an episode of treatment
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative Cagney yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiela yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes 28 zero Nays thank you
very much is that consent look at the
past three are they all consent yes yes
okay the next one on the docket for
coming up today is HP 529 but I already
spoke to that at the beginning of the
day we are not going to be dealing with
this today
um this is going to be taken up and put
on the on the calendar for uh a date to
be following here uh most likely on the
13th of uh
437 relative to reading assessment and
Intervention Program this is also an
early Bill Rick yes
um since you just talked about 529 did
yeah just in the same sort of package
idea
well 27272 is a bill it's not on the
agenda for today oh I thought it was
there it is at the bottom yes so we're
going to hold off on that too right
and just to explain the 272 to it for
uh this this is a bill that
um
puts together
[Music]
the the different weighted uh notes you
yeah this is the Charter Public Schools
right yeah that's correct and this is
the per pupil cost of the Charter Public
Schools and uh whether this be part of
you know it's associated with what we're
discussing here with for 529 and there
is a relationship so we are going to be
putting that discussion together with uh
uh when we
um
break here there will be some work on
that done
um
administrative work on that uh to this
date has not been completed so both
bills would be not taken up today 529
and 272 if there are those there waiting
to hear those today we're not going to
be dealing with 272 either
so going on to 437 relative to a reading
assessment and Intervention Program
uh 437
uh
look to represent codali for a motion uh
thank you Mr chairman I would like to
move on to pass and I will uh offer an
437 it representative made that motion
so represent cordelli you're recognized
uh thank you uh Mr chairman
um
this bill addresses
um literacy in uh New Hampshire
in our schools
it does a number of things
it requires screening
um grades K through three
currently screening is done for dyslexia
this expands it to uh reading literacy
um it provides for Intervention
when there are deficiencies found in the
screening process
it goes
into
involvement uh both with parents getting
parents involved when there was a
deficiency I think it's required that
parents need to be involved and be given
the tools that they can use to help with
the situation with reading at home
um
the uh
intervention will be based on the
science of reading and research over
decades as to how best to Children teach
children how to read
the community should be involved with
this as well
and a major shift also it does away with
differentiated aid for third grade
reading deficiencies which now goes only
to students who do not qualify for one
of the other differentiated Aid
categories of special needs English
language learner or free introduced
luncheon so there's only about 2 200
students who qualify for the
differentiated aid for third grade
reading and replaces it with a reading
Improvement grant that would be
available to
fund assistance in the district for all
those students who have a reading
deficiency
um the original bill
has the median Improvement grade for
third grade the amendment expands it to
both second and third grades
yeah right I will yeah
um
uh so I think those are some of the
major components of what we're trying to
do in this
um
in this legislation
um and um I don't know if the sector
wants to make any comments Mr chair but
I'd be glad to introduce the amendment
uh
um well we're in the discussion phase
right now so you can introduce your
Amendment at this time okay thank you I
um
I mailed it around to everybody this
weekend let me let me see if I have
copies for everybody in my yeah I'm
sorry
[Music]
well there there are some emotional for
wait on that one
you may be able to bring that up even
that time we're discussing this as well
yep
thank you
if I could just add one thing on this
chair
um also in this amendment
um you will see that uh I Incorporated
um
uh
the uh 377 Bill related to uh dyslexia
screening and that's on page four
starting line 16.
okay due to the fact I think some people
are seeing this for the first time would
you just take us uh walk us through the
the amendment from A to Z
in other words first phase through
sure
um
on the first page of the amendment
um starting with uh section one starting
line seven
it basically uh provides for a universal
screener for
um reading and dyslexia
if we are going to be
having
funding these reading Improvement Grants
based on deficiency
believe that there has to be a common
product just like there is with the
state assessment that is used currently
for reading deficiencies
uh the department would be required to
contract for such a screener
there is an appropriation for them
um and I I know in talking with the
Melissa white of the department they
have
already had conversations with uh
several
um
going down further into the changes
there was a comment earlier about uh
um deficiency and we've made both
references to the efficiencies to be
substantial deficiency so it's
covered in both areas
we've included chartered public schools
in several locations you'll see in line
27 and 33 on page two so it's every
District School Board and chartered
Public School shall report annually
shall engage stakeholders
to discuss the importance of reading I
think
we want this not to be a school
classroom effort but a community effort
also to improve literacy in New
Hampshire
um
then
I think
on page four where I mentioned the
edition of 377 the
dyslexia screening
is incorporated there and at the bottom
of page four is the appropriation for
the Department to acquire the universal
screener
and I know that there are
Universal screeners I know the parent
company of uh Dibble has a product that
also incorporates
um
recommended interventions when it
deficiency is is highlighted in the
screening and also has a parent portal
available because one of their sections
of these uh the bill also requires a
notification of parents as to what is
going on with the reading progress that
the child is is hopefully making so you
know there is the possibility for a
screener to Encompass a number of
functions that are called for in the
thank you are there further
questions of Representative cordelli
maybe on on that on this represent miler
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question
uh I noticed that on page four the line
18 you do uh make reference to Dibbles
and my concern
is
identifying a particular product
in a bill we've had problems with that
in the past so I I I'm I'm not I'm not
questioning the need for this kind of a
screening but I am concerned about
identifying a particular product in the
bill so uh why would we why would we do
that that's um that's thank you for the
question that's in current statute
um and it was also in House Bill 377 so
I just carry it forward and um meant to
um change that when I added the
department to acquire Universal
screening tool
um but it slipped by me
foreign
to any great extent um in this
um
in the sentence
um because it says Dibbles or an
equivalent and on page one it does call
for the uh
uh Department to acquire a universal
screener for both functions thank you
represent party all
this is somewhat similar in line eight
on page four
in reference to the science of reading
lower case
however
um
I was trying to find out more
information about this uh as I was
looking over the spell the science of
reading and I and I Googled it and the
first result that came up was actually
um it wasn't identified as an ad so
someone might go there thinking it was
objective information about this
lowercase science of reading but it went
to a company's website amplify so my
concern is sort of some other I'm even
wondering if this phrase the science of
reading which reflects
needs to even be there I'm all for I'm
all for the the other items phone you
make awareness phonics reading fluency
all this stuff online's 10 and 11. my
concern is someone uh in a school local
school district might might similarly be
looking for information in Google
science of reading and be led to this
website which um had a certain agenda
which you know if it was very specific
so thank you okay yes go ahead
um thank you uh the science of reading
is
um a generic term that was
um coined to cover all the research as
you heard in testimony from Melissa
um as you've seen in the handouts that I
gave you I can quote you
um
um that the science of reading is a body
of research over decades it is not a
product
um if you uh I Googled the science of
reading also and got over 5.7 million
hits
so to take a look at one article one
reference
um
um I I think is not uh valid for this it
is not a product no one recognizes it as
a product there might I don't know I
haven't looked at all the products
available someone might have named their
product the science of reading I don't
know but the science of reading in the
context of this bill and all other
legislation that is passed around the
country is that it is based on a body of
research and it in the bill talks about
the components of um what is to be
covered uh not just phonics but fluency
comprehension
Etc is all part of the science of
reading
um
Arkansas for example passed legislation
two or three years ago to uh
they basically mandate
curriculum
um and they passed legislation for the
science of reading to be required but
then went further and I think it's five
or six pages that I looked looked at
provided all the approved curriculum
related to science of reading and
Literacy for their schools to choose
from for K through 12. it goes on for
five or six pages by grade level so it
is not any one particular product it is
a body of research and
um
we talked about Dibbles they recognize
science of reading as a body of research
and not any particular product as do I
think most all the screeners
that I have seen
um
I hope that answers your question
for further discussion representative
Belcher
thank you Mr chair I'd like to also
take a closer look at the phrase science
of reading and just get into what I've
what I'm trying to discover
um around this term because obviously in
the bill
having quotation marks around it it
signaled something to me that it may not
be generic so I looked into it there was
also when it was introduced a pamphlet
or paper from the company amplify
um and I noted the company amplify when
they were using the phrase science of
reading they capitalized the S and the r
which suggested something else to me as
well so I went down various rabbit holes
and indeed I don't disagree that science
of reading is not strictly a product
that that isn't what I I discovered
however
what it does appear to me is that there
was a coalition formed I believe I
actually had a name uh maybe the
defining movement coalition
um they they got together with uh his
various companies various organizations
such as amplify
um
and they formed something called the
reading league if I'm not mistaken
they went on to
um put out various products that are
utilizing what they call the science of
reading and this is not limited to any
particular company as far as I can tell
there's a whole lot of companies that
offer things that are based in what they
call the science of reading however
the science of reading from what I am
able to gather appears to act as
something akin to a cartel that is
designed to legitimize a certain set of
science
and a lot of that was quite good I went
down I listened to
um I believe it's a company amplify puts
out a podcast called science of reading
the podcast I listen to I listened to
most of about half a dozen episodes and
they a lot of it was quite good
however there was some stuff I found in
there that they seem to be legitimating
under the term the science of reading
that I found highly objectionable these
things include a need for
socio-political activism within the
classroom
there was an entire episode that was
unadulterated critical race Theory there
is all kinds of other stuff being done
as far as I can tell under the banner of
Science of reading
so my concern is if we're
if we're using that language
that and we're not trying to point to
any particular set of
set of information that might be linked
to any particular company or anything
else
I would love to see just a very minor
Amendment
to change the language science of
reading to something that makes it very
clear that we're looking for a
evidence-based
set of research
in general as opposed to something that
seems to me to be as I said something
that came to a cartel to legitimate a
certain subset of science that includes
things that I don't think are
needing to be in the classroom
further discussion represent miler
thank you Mr chair uh president cordelli
is it your intent
that this amendment of 437
would take the place of HB 377 and and
Mr chair before we voted this we'd like
the caucus to talk about this once we
go ahead that's a question yes
um
I wanted to try and incorporate 377 so
that we had one consistent piece of
legislation
um whether 377 could go forward
separately
um I I would see it possibly being
retained as a backup
um because who knows what will happen
with this Bill thank you
ref Santana then representative Cascade
and we'll just float around that side
yeah
um as working on 377
and trying to you know everything's
going on trying to to see the screening
and interventions for dyslexia that one
where you say 377 is incorporated and
I see some uh differences from what we
had
um
in the in our bill
um one of them was that they didn't just
do one testing they did
um you have the testing shall be
administered during the second half of
kindergarten and during the first 60
days
for first and second grades and
evidently not third the screening shall
be appropriate at times thereafter and
we've asked for at least two screenings
for dyslexia I think during the time
that's that's one of the big ones I the
the two intense of 377 was one to have
more screening for dyslexia than
currently it happens and the other one
was that when a child is determined to
have substantial issues or dyslexia that
intervention starts immediately rather
than wait
um and I'm not sure that
that those two issues that were key to
377 are included in here
um the other thing is that
I'm wondering about the the financial
note
um there's there's no
um
I think the financial uh part of it
changes a little bit with your Amendment
uh how it's well the amendment I don't
think has a financial mess with it does
it
yes and in the financial note that says
it will use
if you look on the Amendment analysis it
has on the on the last page
the flip over page
um that it establishes procedures for
screening and using Dibbles so that has
to be changed if that's not your intent
you're right I did not have any control
over the analysis uh I'm not sure who
put that in there
um I guarantee you it wasn't me okay and
and I'm just wondering if the the
financial part of it uh where you have
in part on line 30 on
um page four where you go for the
Appropriations there yep
um different than what is currently in
in statute
the appropriation was
um to provide funds for the Department
of Education to acquire that Universal
screening that would do both the reading
because it would be offered as a
Statewide statement excuse me Statewide
tool since we're going to use that as a
measure for the reading Improvement
Grants I felt there had to be a common
base
just um the repeal of RSA 198 48
relatively Grant amounts for
non-proficient people reading is
repealed does that mean that there will
no longer be a grant that that is for
the differentiated Aid that would now be
replaced by the reading Improvement
Grant
the differentiated aid grant is just for
a subset of students at I think it's 740
dollars per student
um the reading Improvement Grant goes up
to a thousand dollars per student and
will would cover all those with a
deficiency okay so that's that's still
yes
um could I address well let's go around
and then do a little summary after
representative cascadden
thank you um I still need this question
answered as to why we need 437 and 377.
and I asked that question
um
because I've been able to
come up with some facts on some
practical experience that for some
reason it just doesn't make sense to me
but if if it should pass then I want to
know why
just to give you a little bit of history
and some clarity of course I've been
trained in re teaching reading taught
reading of supervised reading I've
evaluated reading Specialists
for a long time
in historically the national reading
panel in 2005 came out with the science
of the evidence-based components that
are required to teach reading and those
are the same that are documented in your
bill it's phonics phonemic awareness
fluency vocabulary and comprehension
and after 2005 then there was a big
National push in 2006 seven
to train teachers
to do Universal screeners for our
looking at dyslexic characteristics or
indicators
because another fact is dyslexia is only
diagnosed as a specific learning
disability if there is a discrepancy
between the academic testing and the IQ
which is usually a risk and if there is
a high and a low then the team would
identify specific learning disability is
dyslexia but what we wanted to do after
2005 is not wait for that point but to
be able to screen in kindergarten first
and second grade at least three times a
year and then provide direct
intervention to the student if they were
showing some of those signs and it's not
just one test you got to think of how to
measure all five components
so Dibbles was an early
tool that now if there are people still
using the old Dibbles they should know
that it's not as highly or strongly
correlated
with measuring those
characteristic of someone who may be
dyslexic and again it's never really
clear until interventions have been
provided in K and one and two either in
small in whole group small group or
individual
and if there's documentation Say by mid
second grade that all this has been
provided and this child is still not say
passing Iran which is the rabbit uh the
rapid not the rabbit but the rapid
automated naming which is one of the
very first ones you know it's just rapid
naming because it's Norm by age so
they're wrapping naming uh letters and
then it progresses to numbers and then
it progresses to colors
the Kilpatrick phonological awareness is
another piece of that screening because
it's measuring phonemes do kids know
that b is going to say
um can they put back together by
connecting the phonemes bat
so that's another screener and then some
school districts
um are using star which measures all
five pieces or aims web which measures
all different pieces or they have five
subsets or the new Dibbles now is a
Cadence which is being used and so I
talked to a lot of people in the North
country in this why do we need that
we're doing that
so I went back to the 200 I would say
259 uh colon 59 that was the screening
the first uh law and the first line says
school districts shell screen all public
school students
so I'm thinking well it's here
but then I go to the reading specialist
pursue it to that the doe will secure a
contract Service of a reading specialist
to enable
to gather the data on schools to support
schools
and so that's when we asked for the
report that is done
and in that report
their names a reading specialist that
was contracted to develop this wonderful
tool
that has all kinds of information it is
helpful
but the person named in the
commissioner's report is not in the
acknowledgment page
so I wanted to pursue that and the
contract the person who led this charge
is a different person so I don't know if
what's identified in the report to
develop this guide if that person or
contracted service was part of this
but people on this committee
tell me it was somebody different
and from what I understand I wish it was
a doe person here
um there's a language arts teacher
a great resource
but it's like having your family doctor
as a practitioner and then a reading
specialist being the equivalent of a
cardiologist a specialist
so again there isn't that clear-cut
specialized support yet
and I think I mentioned to
representative cordelli the other day it
seems like we should be pushing for a
full-time doe person who is a
experienced reading specialist
because I think
this law is trying to correct a problem
of some districts
that are not screening for dyslexia
shame on them but is it because their
budgets don't allow them to engage in
purchasing these materials and the
software license that is pretty costly
for the Analytics
and then can they purchase the
intervention tools
and I would want somebody first of all
to get an inventory of that because we
might be talking of only a handful of
districts and what's the reason I mean
shame on leadership if they're not
moving in that direction and selecting
other programs in their budget over
screening and reading interventions
parents need to be a part of this and
the way they need to be a part of it is
preschool skills
parents need to be working with nursery
rhymes for kids it's as simple as that
and when they don't have that once they
come to kindergarten they're learning
rhyming and sounding from scratch
so there is a Continuum of service here
and again I would definitely like to see
the RSA on the books enforced because
it's so necessary
the data right now I think is too early
to say yes the scores are much lower but
we only had one year Beyond covet I
think I don't think it's a fair enough
assessment but if all schools in New
Hampshire were doing these screenings
had the materials they select the
screening whether it's Ames webstar ran
for name you know the path whatever it
is if it does the measuring then they
should be able to know how to decide as
a team what intervention and some
interventions are pretty expensive and
they require training I mean letters
training that's being offered
currently by the department of Ed has
gotten an overwhelming response thank
goodness
our staffs trained in it in 2007 as well
as myself
so yes it took what 15 years for it to
catch up
I don't know but it's the right thing to
do for sure and a Wilson program is more
on a one-on-one
um
intervention but there are several and
people have to be careful because like
representative Belcher said I mean
marketing certain companies and products
they will tell you that they have the
answers
but you have to be Savvy about that in
the 2000s a lot of school districts went
to whole language and they dropped
phonics but we never dropped phonics
because we were old school but guess
what as representative Ladd said that
pendulum went right back and guess what
we need specific phonics direct
instruction and so hey we never left
that bandwagon but a lot of districts
did but I'd want to know who needs help
for the for enforcing this law and
making sure that we have a hundred
percent full-time Personnel that can
take that inventory and support training
in schools money always thank you thank
you very much uh that's that's
informative and it kind of Echoes what I
experienced as a school principal
um I'd have I recall one IEP meeting
which we had and we had a student that
was in our uh
it was very very bright boy
but he had difficulty in this area of
reading and identifying the various
aspects these skills and influencing all
that when we gave him the Wexler
the score was 139
and in our school give or take a couple
points around 130 they were admitted
into the gifted program
and and then when you had a room full of
10 of these gifted students it's like
you walked onto the moon the type of
discussion you were hearing and where we
where they were going
but you know in this particular case
this student did have dyslexia
significantly and it was verified
through that difference that learning
disability between the IQ score and the
what was being performed
and so there's there's a lot to there's
a lot of different ways to assessing
that as well so um thank you very much
for your going through your what you're
doing the school
yes representative cardelli
um
a few things I'm not quite sure where to
start
um first of all
um I take great exception
to people who
um got together to try and put together
some of this research and call them a
cartel
that is inflammatory and out of line I
think for to call professionals who are
trying to improve literacy in this
country a cartel
um I take great exception to that to
um say that something is not
evidence-based research or a program
because it has a capital S instead of a
small S I have no clue as to why we're
going in that direction
and to
equate this with critical race Theory
what are we talking about here you know
I I'm just flabbergasted
um uh the bill says on page two line
eight
evidence-based reading instructional
programming that the teacher will use to
provide
that's what we're talking about that's
what we're talking about we're not
talking about critical race Theory we're
talking about improving literacy
seeing
one word
in one of 5.7 million articles
is not going to change the purpose of
what we're trying to do here to improve
literacy we want to make sure that
everybody is using a screener that is
evidence-based
um
and as you said representative cascadden
I'm not sure what screeners are all
being used but we're trying to put in
place here and provide funding for a
universal screening that does just that
evidence-based reading
determining deficiencies
and providing recommendations for how to
get around those deficiencies or how to
provide interventions to correct those
deficiencies
um
and in terms of reading specialist there
was a separate bill to deal with reading
Specialists because in statute now as
you pointed out is just a contract
Service and we want to make sure that um
that is not the only option for the
Department to have
um
I'll leave it there for now further
further discussion yes represent Balboni
um this is kind of just a simple
question really
um do you have down that the screening
device will be chosen by January 1st
2024 and I would think with any
screening device that's been chosen
there will have to be teacher training
on how to use if
especially if it's a specific one that's
going to be used Statewide and yet at
the end it says the bill will take
effect 60 days after passage so I'm a
little confused with your timing and
making sure that if you do go this route
with a universal screener that there's
adequate time for their teacher training
right
thank you for the question I think that
the uh the the effective date was
um a start that
um the department had to get moving on
uh the process of selecting the screener
and start the whole process not that
um uh everyone had to be up and running
within 60 days with a new screener
president miler
thank you Mr chair and I would I would
concur with uh representative cordell's
comments about
but he just said
the question I guess that I'm raising is
I don't hear any disagreement within the
committee
around the con the the concept of the
need here
what I what I am concerned about is
much of what the representative
cascadden said is that we don't really
have the data
on who's doing what and uh how it's
currently taking place out into the
field
and I was just wondering Mr chair
whether or not again this might be a
bill that we might want to retain
and really have I mean we've had a we
had serious work on special ed issues
when they came before us
and does this fall into the same kind of
category where we can get further data I
mean I'm not I'm not negating the need
here at all
but I'm concerned about
making sure we understand what the
current state of the art is
within school districts
and
um again what representative cascadden
was saying to really look at that and to
see what the incident rate is what
issues are being what are the variety of
options for screening Etc are being used
out there because obviously school
districts have the authority to select
how they want to address this particular
issue and I just feel like I don't have
enough information
to really move on this at this point in
time although I totally recognize the
need for this and so that I guess it's a
question to you Mr chair about whether
or not it would be appropriate to retain
this bill and really do some a further
look at this thing and bring it back
before this committee once we have more
data I hear what you're saying
representative Miler
um it kind of Echoes a little bit of
what we had a discussion with remember
we were we recommended that there be a d
o e analyst
and the purpose for this analyst was to
get down and do that really look at the
Deep dive into our Statewide assessment
and determine where we what we're doing
and to assist the schools in our their
better understanding how they might try
to see Improvement in some of these
subjects I.E reading and Mathematics and
language arts the other components of
language arts
um we don't have that information and
when we look at this right here
in the 2018
formula a funding committee which we had
to study the education funding and the
cost for an opportunity for an adequate
education I'm going to read you one line
right now and this the bill we have in
front of you representative cordelli is
addressing exactly what was stated there
in that bill the dollars that were set
aside for children who are in third
grade and reading below proficient level
has not proven to be a way to improve
proficiency
so that that task force back then saw
that those reading dollars really aren't
achieving what we need to achieve and
then also support representative
cascadden and saying shame on those
districts which are not doing this
um
I can't believe that there's some
districts that wouldn't be doing this
right now it's just unbelievable to me
that that there might be supervisors in
a building or principals allowing that
to happen and sitting there on top of uh
non-profition students and not really
doing that deep dive
maybe they don't have the staff to do it
maybe they don't have the expertise to
do it but there are students being
shoved through the cracks so I I agree
in many aspects of that I don't want to
get too specific in something like this
we know that we have the issues of
a fluency fluency vocabulary phonemic
patterns phonics comprehension
um I won't go through with that litany
again that all that but
I see it and there are a lot of
different ways of addressing this I
would say uh however uh some districts
apparently must need that help but we
don't know which ones those are other
than until we get that deep dive into
the analytics on it and also have the
absolute Specialists that are going to
be able to go beyond and and get into
the real understandings of what it's
going to take to improve these
youngsters be better readers our
students so
where we are with that question whether
it's better to retain right now
um
um or to try to do something quickly
here
um I'm always fearful of trying to do
some quickly
even though we have a lot of there's so
much good meat in this
however there are also those issues
which brought up today so I guess you
know I I'd let your caucus figure that
one out where you go on this and and uh
um even on page one I'm looking at
letter naming fluency phonetic awareness
decoding fluency word reading fluency
oral reading fluency and reading
comprehension and vocabulary
vocabulous not mentioned
um
yeah and I know you can respond that
because if you go to the other Pages it
is it is
um yeah very much so you just go to page
three at the top uh Romans 6 as
mentioned uh so
um
you know I I'm alone between this one
myself but I I think if I had to come
right down on it now if we weren't going
to do it I think we need to do something
I really do and this might be the
vehicle to do it and there's lots of
room to change things as we go on the
process eruption
uh just a quick comment you know on the
department of Ed website where this
guide is there are there's some there's
some FAQs
um and it asks if the law requires
school districts to identify students
who have dyslexia and the answer is no
because again those screeners and those
all those
screeners pre-third grade are not to
identify their to rule out
characteristics and look for risk
factors and it says the law requires
school districts to screen for potential
risk factors of Dyslexia and Related
Disorders and identify students who will
receive interventions based on those
risk factors period
I I don't know that that's any different
than the than the bill but I'm still
looking for that clarity
thank you representative woodcock
thank you chairman
um just a question uh some of the stuff
that comes up in review of the reading
the science of reading I was talking to
the National Council of teacher quality
stuff it's talking about the obviously
the five pillars of the critical pieces
we're saying that only 51 uh at least in
2020 of teacher prep programs are using
the science of reading as the base for
the teaching of reading so I was curious
two things one for uh Dr Chris cadden uh
and one generally for our upper level
the first one was in our New Hampshire
teacher prep programs are we currently
are they currently teaching the science
of reading uh my first question uh my
second pot is if uh half of the teacher
prepped across the country on it are we
in New Hampshire and then secondly that
was sort of to you who's the council the
second to Dr cascadden when
superintendents do uh interviews uh for
elementary people is it traditional to
have ask uh specific question generated
towards their reading expertise and
diagnostic expertise it's not a two-part
one for one for the two leads here
you and Dr kestan do you know what we're
doing in the college over here
I can address the issue uh uh as working
with higher education post-secondary
education right we've had when we've had
post-secondary education in for a number
of topics uh uh one we're seeing a
decline in the number of teachers coming
out of the education institutions in our
state for various reasons we see the
teacher shortage the the question you're
asking though what is being done in the
area of teaching reading in the most
secondary level right I can't answer
that but you know what we discussed the
other day on the oversight committee for
improvement and assessment is that we
wanted to see you know a look into
social studies mathematics I don't think
we mentioned reading at a time but it is
it's just looking into what we're doing
K-12 but also K through 16. yeah and
that's what we have to be looking I do
not know what's going on in the
Department of Education the down the
dean was at our last meeting from UNH uh
that this question wasn't asked perhaps
it's a good question for us to ask and
try to find out what do they have in
these syllabus is that they're teaching
over there right now
um and how are they doing it and I don't
have that answer it's something we need
to find out the second part of Dr
cascaden could answer that for me in
terms of typical if you would uh
superintendent uh thinking or
interviewing questionnaires for
youngsters the teacher qualities at that
time helmetic pieces Mr chair I all set
to answer him yes okay uh yes absolutely
um I was principal of three schools at
the same time with no assistant and yes
um reading and really drilling down on
how much practical experience I've had
in that field but looking at higher ed
okay to six teachers who are
studying to be an elementary teacher
have to take foundations of reading
but then as they go through their
program after a semester two they're
required to take a basic reading math
standardized test call the Praxis one
then before they graduate if they don't
pass that they can't go on in the
program then they have to take a after
semester seven they have to take a
standardized test on science social
studies math and reading
and if they don't pass that they can't
go on in the program
and then to get licensed and certified
they must take a standardized test
called foundations of reading very
specialized
um PSU they have to have 600 hours of
classroom observation 70 days of an
internship what we know of student
teaching UNH has a five-year program
where a student teacher potentially
works with a teacher for a full year and
graduates with a master's so their
teachers are trained and licensed to
teach children how to read and provide
intervention plans when necessary what's
concerning again is
the law says they need to do it why
aren't they doing it
thank you thank you both
representative it's a fair to say that
the instruction that they're receiving
at the post-secondary level is that
there's there are a number of methods
used in the teaching of reading uh a
number of ways to do it we kind of you
know as Educators have gone with that
pendulum all over the board we seem to
think that when it goes over here that's
the best way to do whatever task we're
supposed to be doing and we forget about
some of the proven ways that have been
effective in the past uh is that sort of
what might be happening is that you know
as we've gone with other subjects like
mathematics and the sciences and all
we've gone over there and we've dropped
that is that what's going on in Reading
two at this time
well again when I go back to 2005 that's
what 15 years ago
that's why none of this is new to me so
what people have done in between say
from 2000 and 11 12 to now in the last
10 years I you know I don't know because
I still interviewed
um candidates right up until 2019 and I
those pieces have to be in there yeah
representative cordelli
thank you and represent Tanner
um
uh I believe at one point there was talk
of a an RFP to to examine what was going
on in higher ed teacher instruction I'm
not sure what the status of that is
um but
um this all is a follow-on to an
initiative from the Department
um from April of 2022 the Leaning into
literacy
program that was started by the
um by the department and they contracted
um with these letters
um and I think you mentioned it um
representative to train 9 000 people
in the basically the science of reading
and this new
um idea or this resurrected idea from
research on how to teach children how to
read so
um this is
been going on and I know people who've
signed up to read a former member of
this committee signed up to take the
letters training
um just because she was interested
um so this is an outgrowth of that and a
continuation of that building upon that
initiative
um
and I hope we can continue building to
yes representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um first I I would certainly promote
every every member of this committee to
fully do whatever research on whatever
bill that comes across us necessary to
fully understand what it is we're
passing on this particular bill
I can't tell you how many hours I spent
delving into specifics it was quite a
few I've read hundreds of pages from
multiple organizations and multiple
companies I've listened to hours upon
hours of podcasts a particular podcast
not just any podcast it's a podcast
podcast called the science of reading
the podcast that is produced by the
reading league and amplify amplify was
the company whose handout was provided
to all of us when this bill was
introduced so there is a Nexus here it's
not it's not just Somewhere Out In The
Ether
um now I would certainly not Levy any
accusations that anybody on this
community is trying to do anything wrong
with this I don't think they are I think
we all want to help kids read I want I
think we want it put in place what is
necessary to do that
um I would note podcast season two
episode four that is where you will find
an entire episode that is uh around
critical race Theory
um season two episode three is where
they describe how this science of
reading was formulated in the first in
the first place these various
organizations that come together to
create this body of research now I am a
hundred percent behind using good
science
to inform our teaching methods to help
children learn to read better
100 percent
we've heard that there is no particular
program called the science of reading
if we're not trying to direct our
schools to anything in particular
I don't I don't see why it would be a
problem whatsoever if we just changed
science of reading to what it actually
what we're trying to do which is
something akin to
evidence based or researched Based
Teaching methodologies or pedagogical
methods
um it seems like an easy fix here for me
effective representative Tanner
thank you I just would like to not
forget the dyslexia part of this and
dyslexia
um I believe was after 2005 that that
the real push came
um to to measure to to test kids for
dyslexia and realize that as the reading
specialist told us that dyslexic kids
can can are so smart that they can cover
the fact that they can't read and that
it it may take a couple of testing uh
trials and also testing ways
to discover their disability and then
when it's discovered it needs immediate
intervention and that's what 377 is all
about that's why it's developed and and
I appreciate the fact that it's been
tried to to put in 377 and into this
bill but I think it should be Standalone
and
um I think we we need the extra testing
and we need the the intervention
um immediate so that would be my thought
on this representative cordelli thank
you
um
uh I reject the straw man argument of
the science of reading it's a straw man
come on
um you know it's you know if
if you're going to use
the term as a reason for voting against
this bill be honest about it say you
um in terms of um
incorporating 377 in here all the
intervention is part of it it's not
going to be intervention just for
reading but dyslexia also it's it's all
part of the intervention and the
stakeholders and the parents everybody's
got to be involved for any kind of
reading deficiencies I think and that's
that's why I I tried to merge it in here
as well
um
okay I think we're getting pretty close
to the end of our you know we're kind of
starting to repeat a little bit so what
we need to do is we need to take a break
and have a caucus from both sides on
this bill
um one thing I do want us to note that
we did get into the discussion
representative Woodcock you're inquiring
about post-secondary education and
what's going on there and represent
cascadden did respond to that but on
page three of the amendment under Roman
item D there is reference to the annual
report that comes in from the Department
the New Hampshire teacher preparation
programs implementation of reading
instructional programs so it does
reference to we should be getting
information back from post-secondary
education as well so that's a real
positive Point within this bill yep
so what we will do is we will take a
caucus here and um
and then we'll come back how much time
to about uh 11 30 11 30. yeah
yeah
thank you very much so we will caucus
yeah it's a separate bill so that's that
there has to be it has discussion on yes
because it is a bill we have in New
okay we are now back in in session
and we're looking at HB 437
uh the amendment to 437
and we just broke our caucus
um
at this point in time we got to assess
whether we're ready to move forward as a
total committee on this or for whether
the other option is representative Milo
you so you're at the position would you
so with that
um
I think that rather than going down this
a vote at this point in time can we uh
form a
a small group
um we have the option retaining it or is
feeling amongst your group that it might
be able to be written in a way that it
could move forward so
we believe more information needs to be
gathered on okay so you're absolutely on
okay so I I guess where we're going to
go is we're just going to follow this
through then with taking action today on
this
so we have an amendment on the floor
uh is there any further discussion on
the amendment
not seeing any Madam clerk would you
please call the roll on 437 on the
amendment the amendment uh 437 is
ought to pass it replaces the the entire
bill of 437.
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes
representative Ford yet representative
Belcher yes
representative gagne yes representative
McDonnell yes representative Noble yes
representative Peter now yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler no representative
Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Ellison no
representative Wilcox no representative
Heath no
representative Balboni no Representative
cascadden no representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
10 years 10 days okay the motion fails
represent Miler I'd move to retain this
bill
is there a second
represent Tanner so we have a motion to
made by representative Miler second by
representative Tanner Madam clerk are
you are you nearing readiness
is there any further discussion on the
retained motion begin with
not seeing any amount of clerk
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative electus no
representative Ford no
representative Belcher
yes
oh boy
they don't have that response yeah I
know
representative McDonald
no
representative Noble no
representative Peter now
yes
represented wait
representative cortiello yes
representative Myler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Ellison yes
representative yep
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
oh hold on sorry I did something wait
may I just have a moment to regroup yeah
three
13.
damn
I'm sorry I have it fixed now
15 years five knees
am I correct
I apologize for the confusion no
were just yelled out I started doing
four no I started doing like I just
started writing the wrong number after
three I wrote four when I should have
15 years funny
and representative gagne from another
Canadian we say yes or no
I
that's not what I was taught when I was
brought up as a kid in Toronto
okay
a lot of Canadians around here remember
representative guile
she went to Miguel she was very much a
Canadian
okay
um let's see going down here got about a
half about 25 minutes here before our
lunch
um I'm looking for one that wants to
take us all day
okay we're gonna jump uh down on the uh
agenda a little bit
and we're going to take up
um
what about this one here four
four
okay we're going to go 439 contract with
private schools
4 39.
just a couple numbers beyond what we
represent cordelli I recognize you for a
motion uh thank you I would like to move
uh ought to pass on House Bill 439. okay
uh is there a second
president Belcher second Sam motion 439
is relative to the duty to provide an
education and contracts with private
schools uh
representative cordelli do you have any
discussion
uh thank you
um this fills in a hole that was left
with legislation last year related to
age 21 inclusive for the education of
children with special needs
and it also
repeals a section of Statute that was
not updated uh last year but is a
duplicate
um
of
193.3 in terms of town tuitioning to any
private school
the statute that is being repealed
um was not changed to remove the words
non-sectarian and is is really not
needed since it is covered in 193.3
further discussion
nope further discussion from the
committee representative cascaden do we
know I mean I know the federal laws you
have to add that extra year of age 21 do
we know what the cost is going to be for
a local District
year
yeah yes represent Belcher according to
what we heard from doe testimony this is
already in practice uh so I don't think
it would result in any increase
we we did get those exact figures given
to us last year and it was really
minimal
represent Milo your hand up
sure
well that that's not
represent Balboni uh I just had a
question about the the second part of it
relative to school board contracts with
non-secretary and private schools to
provide education
um I I've got the statute open now and
you said it was a duplicate I'm trying
to find out where you're where it's
duplicating
thank you
um 193 193 colon 3.
uh Romans uh six and seven deals with
the town tuitioning programs
and um
we've changed that last term uh it had
been non-sectarian we removed that to
sorry could you give me that number
against a concussion sure yeah 193 colon
not see any further discussion uh Madam
Clerk
all set yeah the motion is
OTP on HP 439 relative to duty to
provide an education and contracts from
private schools
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative gagne yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative yes representative Miler
no
representative Cornell
yes
representative Tanner no
Representative luno no
representative Ellison no
representative Woodcock no
representative Heath no representative
Balboni no
Representative cascadin no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes
I changed my vault
I can do that can I yes you may I'm no
Corner okay well
um 10 years 10 days
okay the motion fails
is there an alternate motion represent
Sarah second
that's okay and that was moved by
okay ready
yes
Vice chairman cordelli
no
Representative lekkas no
representative Ford no
representative Belcher no
Representative gagne no representative
McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Peter now no Representative cortiello no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Luca yep representative
Heath yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes yes chairman
Ladd no
from a motion Mr chairman
um
we're ready to put across any option on
your team
we'd have to do our work right now but I
mean
well even we just eliminate two right
and then you can leave the rest yeah
that's housekeeping we can do that as
well but then this 189 1A still has
non-sectarian types going there
it just you you just don't touch section
section two just goes
right but but the purpose of the you
know was to remove that because it's
right because non-sectarian private
school is it has been changed elsewhere
in statute to remove non-sectarian
uh
represent cordelli you're recognized
promotion
what can I say I I was trying I was
tripping back we're talking about Canada
and uh French Canadian everything uh our
name's end and I let me explain what's
going on here we once had a chair of
this committee named Mike Balboni
and
just uh it's a cry for a lunch what it
is
so a cry for a break of some sorts yes
yes representative cardelli uh I move
routine is there a second second we have
a motion to retain made by
representative cordelli and second by
representative miler
any discussion on that
not seeing any Madam clerk the motion is
to retain
the bill Facebook 39.
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative lekkas yes representative
Ford yes representative beltzer yes
representative gagne
yes representative McDonald no
representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative courtiello yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative Lou now yes
representative Ellison yes
representative Wilcox yeah
representative Heath yes
representative Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon
yes
chairman Ladd yes
19 years one day
okay the bill will be retained and what
we're going to do is we're going to take
a break right now and
get some lunch go up and stretch her
legs stretch our minds a little bit
and then come back an hour from now
yes
sorry thank you representative we're
that was retained motion so no no never
mind
yep retain is this
episode
there should be some in the office
okay I'd like to go ahead with this
afternoon's exact sessions here and the
first bill that we have up here is
hb102 require high school students to
include
uh to include instruction on the nature
so we're looking at one zero two and I'd
like to recommend represent cordelli
recognize representative cordelli for
emotion
I would move not to pass
is there a second
representative Belcher says yes second
Madam cleric you got that it's cordelli
Belcher
um yes I I think that uh
um probably the original bill
um takes a little bit different tact
than than I would have um uh written and
I think that there is an amendment to be
offered
representative electus or Belcher you
have thank you Mr chair I would like to
introduce Amendment
2023-0312h on this bill I believe
everyone should have a copy in front of
them this bill
um everybody have a copy in front of you
okay so this amendment radically changes
the language of the build actually
completely removes all existing language
and what it does is it takes existing
law
as to how we are educating about certain
um issues such as intolerance and
bigotry and other things that can cause
hatred and it adds just one single word
the word class because historically we
have seen targeting of certain
populations based on class Dynamics as
opposed to other things and I believe
that that achieves perhaps something of
the original intent of the nature of the
bill while making it I think far more
further just so I
you're putting forward the amendment
yes yes is there a second
representative
okay
we're talking out zero three one two H
that's the amendment for one zero two
it's put forth by represent Belcher and
second by representative Lucas because
the other the first motion though
doesn't get reported the first motion
was octopass for the bill
and who made represent cardelli made
that and was second by represent Belcher
we got into discussion and the
discussions brought up this amendment
and now we're at on the amendment right
here we're discussing the amended
version of 102.
yes okay
further discussion on one on the
amendment for one zero two
representative
um
really trying to do is lessen or
preferably eliminate some of these
hatred discrimination
genocide Mass violence Etc
so teaching about the causes can be very
important and one
we notice that one cause is missing that
has come up throughout history going way
back and that's class
so adding that in because that is still
across the world an issue in certain
places so we added that so
representative Belcher added that in
we have a caucus request we will break
I'm gonna go ahead and and continue with
this executive session on one zero two
uh we have an amendment on the floor the
uh motion on the floor for the amount
was ought to pass is there a discussion
representative Miler yes uh
representative
representative Belcher could you define
sure I'm glad you actually give the
opportunity to do this because I meant
to do it earlier so a class I'll give
you a perfect example of what class
would mean for instance during during
World War II
um the ukrainians were targeted as a
class being called kulux the certain
class involved was the peasant farmers
and they were starved to the tune of
millions
um in this incident so class can be
broken down generally as it's generally
considered based on
um wealth or ownership but not
further questions from the committee
well if I may yes one of the one of the
concerns we have is that obviously the
current language that's in the India law
was developed uh with the
input of a social science teachers Etc
and so we have some concern as it
relates to uh the current
review of the 306 rules dealing with
curriculum and we know that that's going
through right now I mean we kind of had
that when we talked about cursive
writing as another in mathematics we
talked about that a little bit too so we
have some concern about
preempting uh a review by those who are
actually involved of teaching this
particular subject so that's those
that's that some of those are the two
concerns that I think that we basically
came up with
further discussion representative
Belcher if I may just speak to that real
quick I I do understand
um the the point you're making I I would
only further point out that
um just just from the point of whether
or not we should and can be doing
something on this nature
um if it's something that can be done at
the state level at the executive branch
um then it's something that we can do
also and whether or not a a certain
teacher or expert based on social
science in the schools would agree with
the matter or not
um
it may influence our opinion on it but
it doesn't it doesn't say anything
regarding whether or not we have the The
discussion Jefferson Cornell
I just still I always have a problem
with dictating to local districts what
their curriculum should be and and I I
believe in local control for local
districts so I I have a hard time
telling them how and what they should be
teaching
uh could you explain to me a little bit
more what you mean by that because I I
don't see the word communism in this at
all
um I only see genocide and Holocaust and
such as
and that's that's involved this is all
in law so the amendment replaces the
communism bill is at yes okay so it's
not so the only new word is the word
class okay thank you you're welcome
further discussion from the committee
not yes representative Tanner so
um the
designation local on this one which is
usually just an L I think but it wrote
it out as local that means that the that
they assume that the local is going to
have to uh
spend some money
is that where local is there the the
previous that the bill as it's
introduced has a requirement that you're
going to have one hour of instruction
okay I believe that's where they're
coming up with the the local thank you
with that torn out of the bill
I I don't believe there would be any
cost on this
further discussion
not seeing map Kirk would you please
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative gagne yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative yes representative
cortiello yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative Woodcock
representative Heath no representative
Balboni no
representative cascadin no
representative Damon
no
okay
I do but I just want to make sure I know
where we're at right now so the
amendment failed because it was tied is
that correct
that's right okay 10 10 there's there's
you know
okay
um
so is there the motion on the floor the
emotion on the floor at the moment is
OTP is it not yeah that's that's so do
we not have to take a vote on that first
before we can no yes we do yes we do
yeah all right thank you
okay is there any further discussion on
this bill
so the mo the bill is up now as it was
introduced
Madam clerk will you please call the
roll
Vice chairman cardelli no
Representative leckis no
representative Ford no
representative Belcher no
Representative gagne no representative
representative Noble
no
representative pattern now yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler no
representative Tanner no
Representative luno no
representative Ellison no
representative
representative Heath no
representative Balboni no
Representative cascabin no
representative Damon no
chairman lad yeah no no
wake up
uh Three A's uh 17 Mays Seventeen three
motion
sorry to you yeah
okay go ahead
I would like to move Ito
second
[Music]
Myler
not having any further discussion on
Madam clerk do you have
you're ready uh Vice chairman
cordelli yes
representative like us yes
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher yes
representative gagne yes
representative pedernal
no
representative courts yellow no
representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes
representative Ellison yes
representative yes
representative Heath yes president
Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman Ladd yes
consent
yes
no Minority Report on that no Minority
Report
okay
nobody already reported no minority
yeah okay so let's go on consent
yes
okay going on now uh we're closing that
and going into uh 435 relative to relief
Aid calculation
to terminating grants for adequate
difference
thank you Mr chairman
um
okay representative Belcher seconds
represent cordelli uh would like to
speak to your motion but just I think
that this was um actually uh
um
a request from the department
and help them by eliminating the
proration and adding the CPI which I
think we probably all favor
further discussion yes
I think we're going to agree on one bill
here represent Belcher thank you Mr
chair I just wanted to note that
reviewing the bill I see no um expansion
of federal programs within the state and
I believe tying the cost of inflation is
is necessary given what we've seen
lately
letting our clerk catch up to us
thank you so we have a motion for OTP on
435 this is a bill relative to relief
and calculation and determining grants
down clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Lucas yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative gagne yes representative
McDonald yes representative
Noble yes representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadin yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
yes 20 years here on A's
um
is there
yeah any problems with consent okay
okay the next spell we have up is HP 440
FN relative to the uses of the education
as soon as everybody's there to four
four zero
I will recognize represent cordelli for
a motion
uh thank you Mr chair
um I would like to move off the pass
second
a representative cordelli
uh thank you Mr chairman
um this is a bill that um
and worked on with the Department of
Education and that
over time
there have been
payments put into statute for various
purposes
um including School infrastructure
grants Etc
to come from the education trust fund
but the
section of Statute related to the
education trust fund was not updated for
those uses so this bill
adds those into this statute
they are referenced in other places in
the rsas
in addition it adds one new provision
which is the lease Aid which is I think
five hundred thousand dollars a year
that is in the budget so if that does
not pass in the budget there will be no
impact
so this is uh really uh anticipating the
um I think that's uh pretty much the
bill
thank you for the discussion
represent miler
you know I think this is a serious bill
uh not that all of our bills
but this um
this deals with the efas and the trust
fund
um
when the trust fund when the efas were
created
there was a little conversation about
how it was going to be paid
it's clearly way over what was the
projected budget
there's currently a lawsuit
I do not believe this is a housekeeping
bill
this is a serious bill that will change
how it is funded
there are several of us who feel that if
you're going to have an EFA program that
it ought to be dealt with with a special
account dealing specifically with efas
so that it does not interfere with other
funding that comes out of the trust fund
so I will be voting against this bill
because I think it is goes Way Beyond
just uh what the department feels that
it's going to be just a housekeeping
Bill and further as I said before
there's currently a legal count a legal
challenges to this in fact the
Department of Education could not
respond to it appropriately because of
the pending legal case before thank you
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair I would just note that um on the
basis of legal challenges anybody can
work in a lawsuit at any time for any
reason
um and while we may be restrained by uh
Court decisions we are certainly not
restrained by pending
um Court action on anything that we do
represent Damon
responding to representative Belcher the
issue is the doe couldn't respond to our
questions because of the lawsuit so
we're not informed
further discussion representative
cordelli
uh thank you uh 194 f11 in the education
Freedom accounts chapter it states the
amount necessary to fund any grants or
transfers of funds authorized under this
chapter is hereby appropriated to the
department from the education trust fund
created under 198.39
we are just adding that to
198.39 but the requirement that the
education trust fund funds come from the
education trust fund are it's already in
statute that this is the place for those
funds to be taken from
further discussion
yes representative thank you
if the
efas are relegated
to come from education trust fund to the
Department of Education why therefore
doesn't the Department of Education be
responsible for
giving out those grants
if it's set up this way it would seem to
me that it's legislating that it is to
be dispersed by the Department of
Education
that's for anybody in the committee
yes representative cordelli
um it is uh in statute that
disbursements are made by the department
but it's also in statute
um from
one uh the EFA chapter 194
F that the process for
um
the uh funds transfer
um and the
uh initiation from the children's
scholarship fund as the current
Management program
um so I don't see the
um the tie between
um any
challenge to the Department of Education
Distributing the funds that's the way it
is established in law currently
further discussion representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair so if this
were to pass wouldn't we then have a
situation particularly with the um with
the voucher program with the with the
education a freedom account program that
um that the
where some of those payments are going
like Amazon and to
religious schools that that they
certainly have administrative costs so
there's that that comes out and then on
top of that the
the the the
contractor who administers the program
takes another 10 so now we're at sort of
10 to 15 percent at the at the profit
level School administration level
another 10 percent at the um the
contractor the education Freedom account
contractor level and now this adds one
percent to the to the Department of
Education so that's another 11 million
dollars
um so uh so now now at least as far as
the sort of Education Freedom accounts
are concerned
um you've got what what looks to be
coming to about 30 percent of those
funds being used to um to administer the
program isn't this sort of really sloppy
management
did anybody gonna respond
love to hear from the Department
the total amount last year was 9.8
percent
I don't know where you get all these
numbers from and how you
pull them up and come up with these 10
millions and all these other Millions
just like the 9 millions that you kept
repeating I have no idea how 9 million
is 10 of next year's budget so I don't
know where all this is coming from but
9.8 percent was the total cost of the
program last term it should be even less
coming up because some of that startup
represent Myler well just to respond to
representative link is you know if it's
9.8 percent
that's pretty close to 10 percent
if I'm going to round up
and I think and I think as we've talked
about this program for a couple of years
now
even representatives from the children's
scholarship fund has indicated it's a 10
so
I'll give you the credit of 0.2 percent
you keep arguing that the education
money that's in the trust fund should go
to public schools and to cost to
administer the public schools on average
is 10 percent
represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair just to
just to go off of the the numbers
assuming that they're that they're
roughly correct what we're talking about
is a scholarship program ultimately that
is a is a bureaucratic leader that
administers funds so students can have
education choice they can go where they
want where their families want them to
go now
I hear the argument that we're doubling
bureaucracy because we have bureaucracy
at the level of the school possibly
unless they're homeschooling and we have
bureaucracy at the level of the
scholarship program the trouble is I
don't hear any argument that actually
takes away that second layer of
bureaucracy because if we did move this
program to the Department of Education
all we're really doing is eliminating a
private scholarship fund that is
currently administering it at a rate
that appears competitive from everything
that I've seen to a government
bureaucracy that we don't know because
we weren't provided with the numbers
what it's going to look like to run it
representative cordelli I just I I think
maybe we're straying a little bit from
now we're talking about the one percent
of the total fund here representative
cascadden
I agree with uh representative Heath on
on the running of the program and
providing doe one percent if they're not
going to run the program but the bottom
line on all of this right now with the
education trust fund
comes from our local property taxpayers
and so I do can't agree
on a poor community
providing additional funds for
management
just can't
notice there are a whole lot of programs
through the years that have been added
kindergarten grants to municipalities
all kinds of
um
low and moderate income homeowners
property tax relief it's a huge number
of programs that we have added since the
education trust fund was first put into
place and so all of those programs
end up
taking a lot of time and effort from at
the doe and so they're not asking for
that one percent for the efas they're
asking for that one percent to run all
of these and it's a huge list of
programs that we have passed and so no
legislature can hold a future
legislature
to
you know to what they've decided and
um so the beginning when the education
trust fund was set up it was just for
that very narrow bit but since then year
after year term after term the
legislature has added all these other
programs so to pick one program out and
say oh we can't add to it well what
about all these other programs we've
added all these years it's it's so we've
already shown that yes we're willing to
take money out of the education trust
fund for all kinds of things because
further discussion
representative Heath thank you Mr gier
the Department of Education goes through
a budget process just like every other
agency in the state they bring forward
their the needs that they have
um the number of employees that they
need to have for whatever purpose they
need
I would think that if they want one
percent of the education trust fund
for management purposes that should be a
conversation that would come up
during the financial conversation around
their budget
I just this
I have not seen this before
during the budget process that an agency
would charge
a percentage for
administering a program for which
actually they're getting paid to
administer
thank you
thank you very much further discussion
not seeing any uh we have a motion on
the floor Madam Clerk
motions OTP
440.
based at the uses of the education trust
fund
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative gagne yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative cortiello
yes representative Miler no
representative Cornell bill
representative Tanner no
Representative luno no representative
Ellison no representative woodcock
representative Heath no representative
Balboni no Representative cascabin no
representative Damon no chairman
yes
yes I I uh asked represent cordelli for
a motion
uh thank you I would move to retain this
bill
is there a second represent Belcher
discussion
yeah go ahead thank you all right if we
retain this bill the the uh fill text is
not going to change correct
so the paying of the EFA out of that and
the the one percent to the to the uh doe
to do the programs they're already
getting money to do anyhow
um so I'm just wondering there's no in
in terms of retaining a bill
is it like a study that we can bring
back a new text just my clarification I
was going to just come back again to be
rediscussed yes there is I think there
is uh the last sentence in this bill is
the one that I've heard the most
discussion regarding correct and with
that
um there are the other components up
there which that's where we are getting
the Appropriations out of that trust
fund to fund those areas correct I think
that's commonly understood
um however the one percent to me
um that that's a lot of money
and and uh so maybe there is room force
and I think there should be some room
for this to be retained and for us to
have future discussions with the
Department as why what generated this
request for one percent I myself am
I also wonder if this procedurally
procedurally if if we allow a doe to add
one percent extra into their budget
after the budget process what about fish
and game what about conservation what
about all the other departments now will
you circumvent it and add in a bill a
one percent for us to keep an EXO I
think it's a really bad precedent I
think something's inside pretty bad as
well but I think that's a really bad
precedent
thank you so this is where I think the
by retaining and working with the
Department we can find some of the
questions out
answers for why this is in this bill
we've had so many bills come at us so
fast we have not had the time to really
you know
um address
um
bills thoroughly the way we have in the
past or tried to in the past last year I
know we had 139 bills but yes
so this bill is IPL versus retained that
the dialogue the issue of discontent
would not be need to be addressed is
I can't answer that I don't know what
the one percent may be used for or you
know I mean just the bill but the bill
is IPL the whole thing is off the table
that that is correct thank you
representative Cornell Thank you um if
the Department of Education wanted this
one percent they could have come to the
hearing and explained to us why they
needed the one percent to go through
legislation rather than it going through
the budget process like every other
department just because I don't think
repeat any other department puts money
into bills asking for money so if the
department had really wanted this and
they could have come and explained to us
what that one percent was going to pay
for I've just been informed that Caitlyn
was here she did not explain that she
she said she couldn't talk about she was
here so I want to make that clear that
she was here but they were but they
wouldn't talk about it no no
you want to talk about the EFA right
I don't recall hearing the question
about that one percent right but my
point was if they wanted if they asked
for this bill and they did the the
amount and they wanted that one percent
I I think it's upon them to explain to
us why they need the one percent here
yeah
further discussion represent luno so
thanks thanks very much Mr chair and and
it's sort of a question but also a
comment
um uh just to make sure that history
doesn't repeat itself but um if this
bill were retained it could then be um
be inserted into the budget
um as other bills uh that were retained
like House Bill 20 which established the
voucher program was jammed into the
budget so um so uh so I I think
um you know cautionary tale for people
who don't want things just jammed into
the budget that did not receive an
affirmative vote a dispositive vote of
of itl would in fact prevent this from
getting jammed into the um well I
shouldn't say that it would certainly
discourage it from being jammed into the
budget but but retaining it um Anything
Could Happen you use the same word again
uh jammed
um
the jamming something into the budget I
think that the there's another
part of the legislative process that's
more characteristic of xenia's Omnibus
bills and creating
hb2 with all kinds of policy that maybe
on the other side of the walls here you
know so
um it you don't have to so but that's
exactly right I think we've all tried
say no more but it keeps going on
so at any rate it's just because uh you
know you may itl doesn't mean you're not
going to see that again this year uh you
may you know from a different angle
yes represent cordelli
um are we sure that the department did
not include that one percent in the
budget
now maybe on the 14th when the
Governor's in town
the motion is to retain the bill you're
welcome
okay Madam clerk would you please uh
call the roll the motion is retain uh
this bill 440 the uses of the education
trust fund
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford yes representative Belcher yes
representative gagne yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative paternal yes
representative yes representative Myler
no representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no representative Ellison no
representative Luca no representative
Heath no representative Balboni no
Representative cascadin no
representative Damon no chairman LED yes
10 years 10 days
representative
I would move to it all this month second
we have a motion up for uh uh itl
presented by representative Miler and
second by representative luno discussion
I'm good thank you
Jefferson Miller
you're good represent Tanner
I just wanted to ask
um
about the one percent again
has that ever happened in the past that
you know of Representative Vlad that uh
that the department has asked for uh
stipend like that
this the first time I've seen language
like this
I don't know whether they've tried in
the past it reps Heath down there she's
been on finance a while too I I've not
foreign
further discussion
not seeing any clerk moved I missed two
moved and secondly represent Myler made
the motion and represented luno seconded
Vice chairman cordelli
no
Representative leckis no representative
Ford
no
representative Belcher no Representative
gagne no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no Representative
pedernal no Representative cortiolo no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
blue now yes representative Ellison yes
representative of Wilcock yeah
representative Heath yes representative
baloney yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman Ladd
no
10 years 10 days
ready
so this is no recommendation and
remember how this works the emotion on
the floor will be ought to pass
The Minority Report with the ought to
pass will come up first
someone will write a report yeah yeah do
you know who's going to be doing that
okay
okay and
540 HB 540 FN
and I'll attempt to adequate education
grant amounts for pupils receiving
and and again we're over to your limit
okay this is uh house bill 540. and uh
call upon representative Ladd for a
motion thank you thank you very much uh
I make the motion OTP on 540. is there a
second
representative Myler thank you uh
representative okay thank you very much
and I'll be quick with this because
we've we've talked about this uh several
times earlier uh in during the uh
hearing process uh this bill deals with
the adequacy formula the components of
differentiated Aid in those four
categories this being one
one of the recommendations that's come
out of the various uh recent two studies
of Education being the commission study
a year ago if time serves me right maybe
it's a year and a half ago
and then out of the task force which met
in 2018
the recommendation was that the the
costs of looking at
um a special education support through
differentiated Aid We're funding all
students to have an IEP at the same rate
now knowing that there are certain
categories of IEPs which require a lot
more service time and expense associated
with it this bill addresses the uh
costing out of the IEP differentiated
aid for special education and a weighted
value format with three categories
category a category B and category C
category a is approximately
um uh it talks about funding at the
current level of
2079.89
category B
4729.78 and category C uh six thousand
two hundred thirty nine dollars and
sixty seven cents
this is based upon reports that are
available uh that the department does
collect they collect reports identifying
those students which require more than
80 percent of the time those are less
that and those which are in hospital
placements or residential placements of
course that is category C we found out
through testimony that the initial
request for categories a b and c was
estimated at seventy three thousand
seventy three million
73.4 million according to what we've
received from the Department the actual
cost would be 83.7 million and the
number of students participating in that
program category a the bulk of our IEP
students is 23 000 kids
in category B approximately nine percent
or seven seven thousand and in the
category C 600 kids so it does um put
more funds into the area differentiated
Aid and this has been requested and
needed for years and I believe it's time
to do so
thank you represent miler
ditto
thank you
um further comments uh from the
committee
I've seen none
um Madam clerk it's to you
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative blackis yes
representative Ford yes representative
Belcher yes representative gagne yes
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes representative
pedernal yes representative cortielo yes
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Ellison yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes representative cascadden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lab
yes
20a0nase thank you very much this will
not go in consent seeing it as a money
issue a significant money issue
I just said that because there's Finance
sitting down at the other that table
agreeing I'm I'm pleased to see that
three left yeah
okay the next one is hb601 relative to
State participation in the Medicaid
direct certification program for free
foreign
House Bill 601 relative to the state
participation in the Medicaid direct
certification program uh representative
Ladd for a motion yes uh move octopass
on 601
representative Cornell second stat
uh
or there's further discussion
no I will defer discussion at this
moment to representative cordelli
uh
thank you
um I don't know if everyone got an
amendment uh passed around if not
um
no
efficient
[Music]
does everybody have a no it's still
does everybody have a copy of it now
represent cornelli
uh thank you Mr chairman
um basically this uh Amendment takes the
uh language uh suggested by Health and
Human Services and does a couple of
things
um first of all it makes the program an
opt-in program
and
and 14 of the third section
and that
the shall provide the applicants the
option to participate in the direct
certification program
the program itself Medicaid is uh opt-in
um and I'll get to another reason in a
moment uh secondly the information that
will be used
for matching between Department of
Education and Department of Health and
Human Services I believe should be
identified and made available to the
person registering when they are
deciding whether to opt in or not
the
bottom section section four
I think it's important
that the commissioners of both
departments
certify
that the process complies with all
and copies made available as as outlined
but I think it's
this is a pilot program I think it's
wise to put this requirement into law
and I think there is a section in our
state law that needs to be looked at in
this regard
and that in um 189 65 which is the
student and teacher information
protection and privacy statute
it defines disclosure as permitting
access to revealing releasing
transferring or otherwise communicating
personally identifiable information
in from the Student Records
the next section 66
Roman 4 says that the department and
each local agency agency shall make
publicly available parents rights
Etc
um an applicable state law including
number c says the right to provide
written consent before school discloses
personally identifiable information from
the Student Records
provided in applicable state and federal
law so I think that it would be wise to
have someone look at these sections of
Law and make sure that the process that
we would be following as part of hb601
in the direct certification program
comply with those sections of state law
and the federal computer matching
further discussion on the amendment
representative Heath
um thank you Mr chair I just said
um being the sponsor of this bill along
with representative luno I just a little
bit concerned about prior to the stat of
a pilot direct certification program
39 currently 39 states are in fact doing
the direct certification and there's a
strong possibility that this will become
um the the
national course of action
um from the Department of Agriculture
with this my it's really a question
would this inhibit that if that were to
be the case
because it would no longer be a pilot
I could yes go ahead
um I I think that the first part of the
bill states that the department
departments shall seek
um participation in the pilot program so
I'm not sure how this would prohibit
anything and it's sometimes um
mysterious how pilot programs just go on
and on and on forever
so I think it's wise to uh put this in
representative cascaden
thank you just a question it would be
ideal if this committee made a decision
on the best interest of kids and not
adults
representative Luna
thank you very much Mr chair actually
and I agree with what um with what
representative cascadden just suggested
but actually a bill
like House Bill 601 is introduced
um is in the best interest of both kids
and adults and and you know pretty
simple explanation why I think as far as
members of the education committee go
but um you know our basically our our
roles of students that participate in
the USDA free and reduced price meals
program not only helps those students
and their parents their families
um have uh have have their students get
free and reduced price meals but it also
helps the taxpayers in those communities
because they get additional funding from
the state
um for um uh uh you know for the
percentages of um of students who are
eligible students not our eligible to
participate in the free and reduced
price meal uh program so that helps
everybody in New Hampshire helps all of
our Tech taxpayers helps all of our
students and to the extent the amendment
is really seeking to to significantly
restrict that I think flies in the face
of um of of you know the the the you
know what we're doing in our adequacy
funding formula to provide
um some Equitable funding for school
districts that that uh that have higher
incidences of instances of poverty in
those communities as sort of predicted
or represented by uh by a student a
number of students or the percentage of
students who participate in the free and
reduced price lunch program
um
and
you know and it and it's sort of it it
occurs to me that the um that the
amendment
um and all of the additional conditions
that uh that it imposes really flies in
direct contradiction to I think a bipart
very strongly bipartisan letter that was
sent uh from our state senate to the
governor's office essentially pleading
with him pleading with the governor
let's participate in this program let's
get on this because it's important for
our kids and it's important for our
taxpayers across the state and and you
know as we you know as we're looking at
this and and that's what the that's
essentially what the bill has has
introduced does
um the amendment I think really
eviscerates that and um and you know and
and uh you know I hope this committee
will um will will find its way to vote
down the amendment vote up on the bill
and do what the governor asked us to do
last
spring or fall whenever whenever we did
it which is to get me a bill that's uh
that that directs us directs his
Department the governor's Department of
Education to participate in the Medicaid
direct certification program and that's
all that's just what the bill does so
I'm hoping this committee will will find
itself in a position to vote no on the
amendment and yes on the bill
I have a race number of responses to
that but that's the bill as opposed to
the amendment should I wait
well we're talking about the amendment
right now please wait
represent Cornell
where the representative some DHHS and
the Department of Education were here we
asked them
um about the sharing of info and they
said they would ask people if they
wanted their info shared with the
Department of Education and they would
only share it if they said yes so I
don't think there's any question of any
information being shared without people
being asked if they do want that
information shared and they've said it's
already been very successful with that
information with SNAP and TANF and there
haven't been problems so I think we're
just this amendment just adds
unnecessary steps to something that's
already working and that the people from
the Departments have told us they can do
representative Tanner
thank you I just wanted to remark
um I I totally did owe everything Patty
said
but in section two where it says such
information shall be limited to the
student's full name date of birth gender
and residence
um are we sure that those are the only
things that the that these two agencies
need to exchange
um and I'm
uh you know it doesn't even have like
parents names in there
um so it seems to me we should find out
from HHS and from doe what information
they really need rather than limiting
them right now before we even uh get the
program underway
further discussion represent Myler
well thank you Mr chair I've got a
question here on line 14 of the
amendment
the SEC to elect to participant in the
direct certification program
my notes indicate that there needed to
be an amendment for them to opt out
of the program
I mean my sense is is that if you go
through the forms Etc you're already in
so why would I have to elect to be in
if I've initiated participation in it so
I guess I'm confused on the issue of the
participate to elect to participate in
the direct certification vis-a-vis but
my notes say here that there needed to
be amendment to opt out
and somebody clarify that for me please
yeah I I think that
um
there was discussion of opting out of
the program
um it seems to me that there would be
um something along the lines of a check
box or a drop down to either say I want
to participate or I don't want to
participate
um basically the amendment says that
consciously say yes I do want to
participate they're not going to
automatically be part of the program if
they don't check a box or something they
have to check the box and said yeah put
further discussion representative
woodcock
video channel LED um
my concern is this
this amendment is a handicapped
providing an additional set of meals to
youngsters they told us that right now
there are 38 000 youngsters in schools
receiving pre-induced lunches that would
expand to 46
000 additional youngsters if we use
direct certification not not any other
type of information at all the data was
safe the author was there all this is
saying listen we know we have 8 000 kids
as parents for some reason are not able
to success access the program this is
providing opportunity to see kids for
doing nothing additional hard work it's
a data safe doe says status say DHA set
a status safe and all we're going to do
is capture those kids that are missing
now this is pretty simple
further discussion
representative cardelli I've seen many
companies Home Depot Banks Etc that said
at data safe but then we hear reports
about data breaches and all sorts of
things so
um uh I also point out that we have a
number half dozen
statutes in our law specifically related
to students privacy and teacher privacy
of information it's it's an important
area as well as federal law uh FERPA
which says
FERPA allows schools to disclose those
records without consent to the following
parties under following conditions I'm
not sure that this is one of those nine
or ten conditions that's why I think
it's important to have someone say yes
we've looked at this and this is fine in
relation to state and federal law I
think it's a safeguard for us and for
everyone participating in the program
further discussion represent Damon
thank you Mr chair two things
it seems improbable to me that 39 states
that are already implementing this
program are violating FERPA and nobody's
noticed so clearly it can be done
independent of that on the New Hampshire
hunger Solutions fact sheet presented at
the hearing
I noted that state administrative costs
decreased
after the pilot project to less than one
cent per student in 80 of those States
this program costs nothing essentially
to feed children and improve education
funding I don't know what we're waiting
for
further discussion
not seeing Madam clerk would you please
call the roll on the amendment the
amendment is ought to pass did I mean
was it just for discussion or should I
do I have to move it
was there a motion no that's what I was
going to ask okay we need a motion so I
okay and is there a second
motion uh this on the amendment the
amendment is zero three five zero H and
it's that amendment that you have in
front of you this would be Amendment to
otps yeah OTP and but we need a second
represental
okay now we're ready for either further
discussion if you want or we can go
right into the vote I think we've had
the discussion
the vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford
no
representative Belcher
yes
representative
yeah I'm sorry
you said yes right okay
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble yes
representative pattern now yes
representative Corey tiello yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no
representative Tanner no Representative
luno no
representative Ellison no
representative Woodcock go
representative Heath no
Representative no
Representative cascadin no
representative Damon no
chairman lad yes
nine years 11 days
okay now we have the main Motion in
front of us ought to pass on 601
put that Amendment aside
and I will speak a little bit to this
bill
um
I'm a co-sponsor on this bill and I
absolutely support direct Medicaid and I
will vote in favor of the bill as it is
right now we have worked with HHS and we
have worked with Des we've had Mr
lippman in here we've had uh doe in here
and we've heard how we had to have a
workaround in terms of permission from
the parent to have their Medicaid
Eligibility used to assist us in the
national food service program the meal
program and then simply a check off for
a pull down box however they want to set
that up but there is agreement between
HHS and and doe that that will occur
that that we've heard
we have also a number of students and
we've been talking about these students
for years
in the high school we are losing out on
count
and due to that we are losing out on
funding
and we also are having students which
are just you know nutritionally you know
there's nutritionists here so I'm not
going to get in that domain I I love ice
cream
um okay so but at any rate there this is
a program I feel that it's a it's a
workaround which we've been able to
resolve in previous years we hadn't
gotten there this is the same bill that
uh came out of this joint subcommittee
which we had was it last year last year
of which we recognized
and we move forward and we even passed
the darn bill
but then there's all this acrimony after
that
um and I I feel at this point in time if
you look at those 39 states are involved
with that you have red and blue States
no question
and so I don't think this is really a
politics issue this is an issue dealing
with uh in our revenues you know we talk
about we haven't talked about that I'll
let Finance talk about that whether it's
20 or 40 million dollars but it there
there are some significant factors here
with this I see more bang for the buck
believe it or not in this program than I
do even in school building 8. School
building Aid affects one two maybe three
schools a year that's great for them but
Statewide it doesn't reach this program
reaches every district and so that will
be the impact for direct Medicaid and so
with that I will support this bill it's
it's a it's a it's a timely measure and
we need to move forward and and get
involved with this program thank you
further discussion represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um I just want to be clear and examine
what we're actually talking about doing
here which is it's entering a new
federal pilot program put on by the USDA
and it's looking to expand our access to
the uh an existing Federal program
um
now let's talk about what's going on
some of the problems we're dealing with
in the schools we've talked we've seen
lately we're going to hold a hearing in
this room pretty soon we'll hear from
people about some of the inappropriate
books that have made their way into some
School classrooms and into some
libraries how do you think someone got
there
Federal mandates from federal programs
where you think Common Core comes from
federal mandates and federal programs
I've heard people say that the cost to
us is nothing to enter into this
I disagree the cost to us to enter into
these Federal programs is State
sovereignty
we seed the powers do this body as
enumerated in the state of New Hampshire
Constitution and we give those powers to
the federal government to hold us
basically at at harm
in order to get Federal funding from
them
I believe that's a process that across
the board needs to be reversed that is
why I will not be supporting this
representative
I have a whole lot of questions about
this program
and an alternate alternative solution
I spent some time talking to our numbers
people who were here
um one of the issues I have is
supposedly they will be
directly
um
okaying the food program and yet we are
not sending any of our information also
supposedly to the federal government
we're only sending numbers well if we're
only sending numbers how are we getting
those lists
either we're sending more than either
we're sending more than just numbers or
all they're doing is giving us
permission to use our own data
to do data matching and why do we have
to go to the federal government to do
that well because they put those strings
on it
and we can't even use our own data
um
as far as funding goes and using those
numbers for funding
we can get those numbers currently
according to the USDA and everything
that our own Medicaid has permission to
share the numbers of people on Medicaid
Town by town so we don't have to enter
another Federal program with Federal
strings who may not let us opt out like
they were talking about he may not let
us do anything and once we are in that
program they hold all of our free and
reduced lunch students hostage all of
that money hostage should we again it
says right in the application if we
apply for the program we promise we will
follow through and they have the right
to change the qualification
qualifications and everything else at
any time so at any time they can require
anything else they want and if we don't
and if we disagree like we say no we
want our parents to be able to opt out
oh all they can sell they have full
right to say fine you cannot do that but
we're not going to give you any free and
reduced luncheon money anymore
and they I mean we've seen that in just
the last few years fine we're going to
withhold your Medicaid money fine we're
going to withhold your Medicare money if
I you know if you don't do what we say
and so why should we entangle ourselves
further with the federal government when
we have a method right now that we could
use and this was suggested by the many
people who came and talked to us that
they can right now release
to us per town the number of students or
the number of people in any town on
Medicaid which completely eliminates the
the
issue of
older kids not wanting to be on free and
reduced lunch
you know and therefore our numbers are
low we still get their numbers
they don't have to take home a piece of
paper and apply when they don't want to
we still get their numbers it also the
whole thing with
tax evaluations as we talked about
that's a measure of wealth and not a
measure of income which you then have
towns who yes their property values went
up but no they didn't get any more money
they won't unless they sell their
property it gets rid of all of that we
can it is a different way of coming up
with funding that we have at our access
at our fingertips right now
that we can use and that's the Medicaid
numbers so many per town and we can use
that to come up with a you know to with
our own funding formula where we don't
have to rely on free and reduced lunch
and we don't have to rely on on
um
um evaluation that can that can unfairly
Target towns that have
uh
great increase in
in uh desirability while because they
have low
availability and therefore you know the
most recent thing buildings that sold
sold High
that's fair within a community because
everybody gets taxed the same within
that Community but when you're comparing
communities if we're in community
suddenly becomes popular
that doesn't mean those people who live
there have any more money but now
suddenly they're getting less money for
to educate their students because the
last few buildings that sold
were sold for a lot of money thank you
that at any rate
representative Woodcock do you have a
represent Alice oh thank you Mr chair uh
frankly my head is spinning we're
getting into local real estate uh the
cost of houses the cost of doing a
number of things
entangling ourselves with the federal
government this bill if it's passed is
going to feed 9 000 more New Hampshire
kids and I will vote for any bill that
increases funding for feeding kids
I think the important part is it
increases eligibility well okay for our
program and that's that's I know that's
what you meant
I'll take six thousand how's that we're
getting wild up here it certainly is
representative
cascadden thank you Mr chair
um I want to speak for the people who
cannot have a voice at this table and
that's all of our kids
and I will definitely support 601
because I went on record
um that I am doing my part whatever I
can do to decrease food insecurity in
thank you representative cordelli
thank you
um I see uh a larger problem here in
that we have data matching already going
on Direct certification for snap and
TANF
it's nowhere in statute
nowhere in rules as we heard
it was done agreement between a couple
of executive departments and the FEDS no
legislative input
I think that's a huge problem we heard
testimony that they had an opt-out
provision
um I think it was for SNAP but somehow
it went away in the quote last
Administration and they're looking at
bringing it back now
but there's no no nothing in statute we
don't have any input hands off now
but yet
this the opt-out went away from that
program who's to say it's not going to
go away from this program and tell me
where does this go in statute it is not
going in statute anywhere there is no
RSA identified here it's going to be the
same type thing as with the snap and tan
of programs it's not in statute it's an
act it's they're just going to make the
further discussion represent paternal
yes thank you
um I'm on the U.S well I have a handout
that I printed from the USDA food and
nutrition service and this from
September 10 2021 but it says direct
certification has the potential to
improve student access to school meals
reduce administrative burden for schools
and families and improve certification
accuracy but cannot be used to
negatively impact any child
I'm just wondering if there's 39 States
involved in this already do we have any
information that shows that they've
improved their ability to
feed students
but use by using this program
representative Heath
um the state that I know the most about
is Massachusetts and the school
districts have been very pleased with
this they don't have to send home the
frame reduced lunch forms anymore the
overall amount of federal funds being
sent to a school district is driven by
those counts and this makes it more
accurate as I said
um previously when I was here the other
day that it's so important to have good
accurate numbers about the children who
are living in disadvantaged households
and um in terms of the the Department of
Agriculture when they developed this
program the direct certification program
in fact
the other programs were in existence and
it was in federal legislation so the
states just adopted those practices in
the case of Medicaid that had not been
put into statute yet and that's why it's
a new program to this process
in actuality what this bill really does
is simply it directs Health and Human
Services and the Department of Education
to enroll the state in this direct
certification program the winner of all
of this of the children
and their their it will decrease the
overall number of Portugal not poor
children children being hungry so I mean
it's a win-win for schools the
Manchester school district has made this
a priority they asked me to submit this
bill
um and those of us who represent the
city of Manchester they asked us to make
this a priority so um they felt it was
very important it will increase the
number of children that are eligible it
will decrease the amount of
administrative paperwork in the states
as we've seen in Massachusetts
superintendents love it because they
don't have to chase a lot of paperwork
getting those papers home to parents and
back
people don't always do it they don't
always find the way home
um kids forget about it in their
backpack they get washed any number of
things happen to them and this
alleviates all that
and it's just all the way around it's
better it's better for our food
nutrition program at the department of
Ed they have better numbers so I really
and truly hope you'll support this bill
it is it is a good thing and it will do
good things I just really can't see
anything negative about it
um there are some pieces of legislation
in our doe that may have to be tweaked a
little bit I don't know but the
information that's being asked I believe
um right now
um it's very possible the way it stands
now and the way the department and
Health and Human Services described it
when they were here made it absolutely
positive that if a parent did not want
their information shared they did not
want their child to participate then
they do have an opt-out option there so
I hope you consider this it's really
it's a win-win for US state thank you
for the discussion
represent Damon
thank you Mr chair just a little further
uh response to representative pedernal's
question Texas has been doing Medicaid
direct certification for seven years
they've seen a 48 increase in children
certified for School meals
and New Hampshire has been using direct
certification for snap and tana for 16
years so
we're extending something that is not
really new in the way information is
shared
thank you thank you further discussion
not seeing any amount of clerk would you
please call a roll at 601 the motion is
ought to pass this bill is relative to
State participation in Medicaid direct
certification program for free and
reduced price School meals
Vice chairman cordelli no
Representative leckis no
representative Ford yes
representative Belcher no
Representative gagne no
representative McDonald yes
representative Noble no
Representative pedernal no
representative Corey tiello no
representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes
representative Ellison
yes representative Wilcock yes
representative Heath yes representative
Balboni yes
representative cascadden yes
representative Damon
yes thank you
chairman Ladd yes
just one of our just one of our comments
a comment on this this is probably one
of the more important bills that we've
acted upon this year
and um
well no more comment Mr chair I request
a five minute break please yes I think
yes I am yeah yes yes yes yes yes I'm
not doing minority okay oh that's great
the chairs oh right yeah you can't do
um
down on him okay we're ready to go ahead
and and uh start back into our last two
bills which we have today the the first
bill in the docket right now is four six
seven
um four six four excuse me
uh relative to eligible students in the
foreign
okay representative liquor recognized
for a motion
okay here
you representative
sorry I seem to have misplaced my copy
of the bill but I would like to move OTP
okay motion made by representative and
second by represent Belcher
represent are you
prepared or do you want someone to pass
It's Magic it's just magic
it just disappeared somewhere I'm not
sure where
um the idea behind this bill is to add
certain classes of students
automatically to the EFA regardless of
their income level
um
thank you very much
and
okay
and many of these are children for whom
um
whether they're moving around between
one school and another if they were in
the public school or whether they were
in the public school and had problems
with bullying and other issues
it is
um reasonable for them to be not in the
public school and this provides funding
for those students
still to be able to get an adequate
education using
adequate education funds
regardless of how much money their
parents make and a lot of these they
those who are placed in in foster care
and whatever we don't even know
necessarily how much their parents make
and the foster care people that's
irrelevant
so at any rate I would ask that you pass
this please
further discussion represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and I would just um
second that and elaborate that this bill
really looks at students with special
circumstances students who are who may
be um children of our soldiers who have
to move around a lot children who have
been bullied repeatedly at their schools
and just because their parents are are
middle class not even wealthy middle
class doesn't mean they should be
prohibited from using the EFA program to
move their child to a safer environment
um and that that's the nature of this
bill it shouldn't be it shouldn't be
particularly objectionable it probably
doesn't affect a ton of students
that's it thank you for the discussion
represent woodcock
this thing I was like
um I understand the intent of the bill
um it clearly securely opens uh the
eligibility for uh certain uh uh groups
of students uh
I'm not sure that the bullying is listed
in here is one of the categories but
probably is I guess persistent
persistently but you know how you
measure that but that's not my issue my
issue is the same one not the same one
one of the same ones that have
repeatedly representative ads since this
bill uh came to uh B and that is once
the initial threshold of Eligibility is
established it should be in my mind like
any other eligibility program that you
recertify on a regular basis uh and not
that you come in once and then you
whatever your income level is it that
you're there forever the intent of
Eligibility programs is exactly that to
keep those that are eligible within that
guideline
um or certain in this particular case as
an income domain and in the larger
program which is the part of it's not
there you qualify one year and you
qualify forever and just seeing it
doesn't seem to make any sense to me you
make 57 000 as a family of four and
Conway you're eligible for these major
eligible for poverty you make 250 000
you're not
that's not what this says year two year
three just keeps going up so uh just for
that part alone I think I think it's a
very uh poorly presented bill in terms
of that requisite thank you
yes I will remind you that when this
this
idea of efas was originally introduced
there was no cap it was never intended
to be only for poor people but
um the reason for only having them
qualify the first year was so you don't
keep yanking a kid around depending upon
how much how much money their parents
make that year they have a good year so
now we've got to take them out of the
EFA and now they can't afford to go
wherever they were going and were happy
and so they end up back in the public
school but then the next year their
parents have a worse year and now we
yank them out you know the whole idea
was
find a place that works for the kid and
leave them there and not keep yanking
them around depending upon how much
money a parent makes that year compared
to the next year further discussion
representative Luna yeah thank you very
much Mr chair so it so if um if a parent
goes from uh or family goes from
qualifying for an EFA in one year and
then maybe another a year later they
they do really well uh financially
um
under current law I believe they have to
they they can stay in the uh the EFA
because there's no annual thing but if
there were an annual
um thing I think is what you were
talking about
uh would there be a requirement when the
parents are doing Financial well for the
student to leave the private school that
they're going to I'm not quite sure I
followed what you're saying
that was the whole point because just
because they make that little bit more
doesn't mean they can still they can
afford to send their kid to that private
school and so now they have to remove
them from the private school for that
year and then the next year maybe the
parents do worse and then they can put
them back in the private school and as I
said originally it was never intended to
be income based but even as it was it
was written in that they didn't have to
re-qualify because we didn't want to be
moving kids around if they found
something that worked we wanted to make
sure they could stay regardless of the
fluctuations of their parents income
just because a parent makes 300 and 54
instead of 300 percent doesn't mean they
can pay for that
um private school
on their own
representative Tanner
thank you I I find it ironic I well
first of all I think this bill is more
about
um categories rather than money uh
income levels which you've been debating
but I think it's ironic that the public
school one of the one of the best things
about it is it's a safety net for kids
and it's a safety net almost for kids in
all these different categories
some of whose parents are neglectful
some whose parents are
just not there some whose parents can't
support their child for one reason
another mental illness or income level
or whatever the situation is
and I just uh and the school has the
public school has
set up and bent over backwards in my
estimation to meet the needs of kids in
each one of these categories and there's
outs for them in each one of these
categories that manifest hardship that
we talked about before for a very few
kids
that um
you know qualify for that and um
therefore I can't vote for this
um or I won't vote for this I'll vote no
for this I guess
um against the OTP because I think this
is what what
the for me is one of the main reasons
Public Schools exist as a safety after
kids
thank you
further discussion
represent cordelli thank you
um
but as we've heard in radio ads from Nea
every child is unique and learns
differently
and every child might not have the
perfect match in their local public
school that is mandated to them by their
address
um these children in particular that
we're talking about in these situations
where they've
been granted a manifest education
hardship by the local school district or
superintendent because
they're not fitting in due to any number
of circumstances I know of a case where
the child was persistently bullied
that's another one of the categories
here that child was granted a manifest
education hardship but was denied
admittance to the school next School in
the next District
um I I think that these children were
that we're talking about here and and
yes it's it's about the children
um these children
um might need
um uh situations other than their local
public school and because of um income
that might fluctuate any number of
circumstances
um divorce Etc
um I I think that they shouldn't be shut
out of getting the opportunity for the
further discussion yes representative uh
and then represent Belcher
I just want to respond to this idea of
public school as a safety net
um just pointing out because I can't I
can't help it is that persistently
bullied students and persistently
students in a persistently dangerous
school have obviously not not found that
when we failed them there so that's just
two I just want to speak up for those
two groups just put that out there
representative Belcher thank you Mr
chair I just I just wanted to make the
very brief point that
when we're talking about spending this
money on on these students it's not like
we're sending this money overseas or
something like that we are talking about
New Hampshire residents New Hampshire
taxpayers who have paid into this system
just like they paid in the Social
Security their entire lives and all
they're looking for is to be able to
utilize that promise that we made to
them
for education
thank you represent McDonald thank you
Mr chair
[Laughter]
I guess you're done you're welcome
so what you do it's just shopping with
I would like to say that on this
committee we are responsible for
students and for children and no student
should suffer because of their parents
inability to pay and just as we were
talking about moments ago relating to
feeding children a student shouldn't go
hungry because of their parents
inability to pay for a meal and in the
same way these students who are equally
as vulnerable in other ways such as
persistently bullied we had someone
testify about the safety concerns of her
son and she moved her child to a
different model from the traditional
Public School model and she found it was
safer and should that student suffer
because of her his parents on ability to
pay and just as we were talking moments
ago I see it similarly to feeding
students no student really should suffer
and that's why I support this program
wholeheartedly thank you thank you
further discussion represent Tanner yeah
I just uh would like to point out that
again we're talking about guard rails
for the program and and safe safety net
is the is the guard rails for for public
education and also that
that
um I I remember that uh the woman that
came with the with the child that was
bullied and got a manifest hardship and
she was
appalled actually well I'd take that
back she was extremely upset because she
could not find another school that would
take her child whether it was a school
close to her or whatever and I just want
to point out how school choice is really
with the schools not with the parents
that if the if a parent wanted their
child to go to say Phillips Exeter
Academy
um Phillips Exeter Academy still screens
that child to decide whether they want
that child or not so
represent Ellison oh thank you Mr chair
one of the categories in the bill is is
talks about
uh eligibility because the the students
enrolled in a I guess persistently
dangerous school you know and it cites
RSA
193-g dot one is there anyone that knows
how many persistently dangerous schools
have been identified by the Department
person Damon you know
that question was asked after the
hearing and I was told that there have
not been any in New Hampshire for the 12
further further questions from the
committee
not seeing any uh Madam clerk we have a
OTP
on on the bill 464.
brought to eligible students in the
Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative leckis yes representative
Ford
yes representative Belcher yes
representative gagne yes representative
McDonald yes representative Noble yes
representative pedernal yes
representative cortiello yes
representative Miler no
representative Cornell no representative
Tanner no Representative luno no
representative Ellison no representative
Wilcox no representative Heath no
representative Balboni
Representative cascadden no
representative Damon no
chairman Ladd yes 10 years 10 days hear
him in lad most fails yes I'd like to
make a motion itl please okay motion's
been made by representative Tanner to
itl and second by represent Miler
represent Tanner you recognized
um once again
um I I think that um
the uh the public school system is the
safety net and uh covers a lot of these
areas and
that um
I'm I we need guard rails for this
program
further discussion representative
Cornell and I just like I checked the
online
um support and opposition to this and I
just like to bring up the um 300 people
opposed to this bill and 27 supported it
um which I know sometimes doesn't matter
because the last time we discussed this
4 000 people opposed it and I think
there were only 300 that supported it
but the the people that signed in online
represent Damon
I will be voting against this bill and
any other bills to expand the EFA
program until we have an accountability
system for what quality of Education
those students are getting that is
comparable or the same as the public
schools
I just want to relate an experience that
I had and
the only way I could have helped in this
experience well what happened is I had a
granddaughter that was in eighth grade
and that had been bullied and bullied
and bullied
and I had a wonderful relationship with
the principal and with the counselor as
well and the teachers but the bullying
continued on the side from the students
and it couldn't be stopped and at the
eighth end of the eighth grade I had to
make that decision along with my wife
what are we going to do
it's going to go on again now to the
high school from the Middle School
and have this trailing behind her
and there was only one option in the
valley that I live in one option
and that was to go to St Johnsbury
Academy
over in Vermont that caused 60 at the
we felt that we really had to figure out
how to pay that tuition and we did but
an EFA would have certainly helped
because my income level was that above
the 300 percent
and so there was no other option for us
we made the right decision
she graded for graduated from Saint Jay
went on to Dean's List for four years at
UMaine and Captain the track team
and and was a very very successful
student however when she left that
Middle School
she was right down in the dumps and we
couldn't help in any way we we tried
everything so there are situations I
believe where the EFA program really
does serve a purpose and that's one of
them where if it had been a place
it would have helped grandpa in terms of
trying to come up with that part of the
money so that's where things are
programs like this do help
okay we're going to we we're you know if
there's any more discussion here
would uh Madam clerk would you please
call the roll
this is on 460 let's see Excuse me yes
um yeah 464 relative to eligible
students in the education Freedom
Vice chairman cordelli
no
Representative leckis no representative
Ford
no
representative Belcher no Representative
gagne no representative McDonald no
representative Noble no representative
Peter now no Representative cortielo no
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Ellison yes
representative Wilcox representative
Heath yes representative Balboni yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes
chairman lad no
10 years 10 days so again we have no
recommendation
um
who's going to write the the Army okay
Tanner has the report and who's writing
for the majority
okay
okay we have one bill left today
um I believe it's 377 jumping around we
have been but that looks to me by the
uh relative to screening and
intervention in public schools for
seems like we started the day talking
about dyslexia and here we are at the
yeah I'll make a motion on OTP women
stream
who we have down there
represent Belcher you recognized for a
motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
purpose and Belcher would you like to uh
did you get that represent Belcher would
you
yes thank you Mr chair and I'll explain
my rationale here and my other people
are free to explain if they have other
rationales
um so let me first say current law
uh authorizer rather mandates a testing
for
um dyslexia upon entry to kindergarten
or first grade as well as inappropriate
times thereafter
this bill would seek to increase that by
quite a lot I believe
maybe seven overall at least
um we heard in testimony from the
experts over the view that this task
like any test is not perfect
that there is an error rate in this test
for false positives and we do not know
what that rate is as of right now I
think it would be an appropriate to move
forward without knowing what that rate
is because very simply put
at some point there's a correct number
of tests where we're kind of going to
Plate two we get the correct number but
then when we continue testing after that
point we're going to be catching more
people who don't have dyslexia but have
false positives and they're going to
have their educations disrupted
perhaps mildly perhaps severely
depending on if they get placed on a
pathway to an IEP or something like that
they don't actually need so I would like
to see the numbers involved for an error
rate on this test before we take action
on increasing rates beyond what they
represent Tanner
yes
um I don't know what it is with Felts
positives
um they're usually relatively small when
a test has been gone through and and put
on the market and substantiated so I
really don't have that number but it's
my my
um experience with testing is that if
it's an approved test the error rates
low
um
I have an amendment to this bill which
will speak to the number of tests
[Applause]
um dyslexia as we heard from people that
came here is devastating that oftentimes
because it's the person is of high
intelligence and can hide the dyslexia
and the ability the fact that they can't
read for many years and then when it
finally catches up with them uh they've
they've been through a period of time
where they can't read and I think I
mentioned this before
I used to teach swimming and if somebody
didn't know how to swim before they were
it was very difficult to teach them
swimming much more difficult than it is
when they're younger and dyslexia
reading is the same thing that if they
can't read and they get to a certain
level it's very difficult and they
suffer a lot of discrimination up to
that point as well for being a
non-reader so I think this bill is you
shouldn't be retained it needs to be
looked at right now people in the
dyslexia group were the people that that
actually sponsored this bill and and
came forward saying that you know they
had a child that wasn't diagnosed until
after third grade and had not received
the adequate testing
so I think
um I will definitely be voting against
the retainment motion thank you uh
representative Tanner what is the
amendment number that you do have there
um
oh because I'm looking at zero two three
four h yeah that was your preceding
would you please hand that out to the
committee
yeah
beautiful
foreign
we do have a motion on on
emotions for me to retain but we're in
the discussion phase here so I would
like to ask at this point in time
represent Tanner could you explain
what's the difference between zero three
five seven H and
yeah
the preceding one you had zero two three
four each
okay uh the one that I had before
um
sorry thank you
in line 18 uh we had a question about
whether how many it said 60 days and
we've changed that to 60 school days
um so the initial screening shall be
completed no later than 60 school days
of a student entering the screening
shall be repeated one additional time
during the current school year and
repeated at a minimum of twice yearly
through third grade so it isn't the
um repeated wanted you know
several times
um
they let's see the other change on line
27 you had in the previous Bill the
school shall promptly inform this one
says the school shall inform right and
promptly was taken out because there's
no way to measure promptly
um and let's see
um
excuse me and on the back side of the um
the part about the
thousand dollars the the uh
reimbursement has been dropped from the
bill
so it no longer has that part about the
reimbursement
um
I think that's it it's kind of hard
because
know so I'm going to request that we
have a caucus for a few moments we
haven't had a chance to look at this and
um
I see it does reflect several of the
changes which had been brought up
at the previous meeting with days it's
not defining it as
um
school days which is
it helps really pin it down that's a big
one yeah and the and shall inform
uh verse shall promptly promptly it's
one of those lawyer words right and the
and the um well I guess that was taken
out in the past
in the last Amendment we took out the
dibles
highly trained uh on I think it's 9 11.
um
because Hailey was a you know kind of a
subjective thing so
yeah okay
um let's take uh uh a short caucus here
thank you
okay we're we're back in exact active
session right now and I think here's the
the game plan for this one we're not
trying to move the goal post farther
back we what we recognize here is that
there is this is a very important topic
we've had several bills we've talked uh
quite a bit about you know intervention
reading dyslexia
um screening of that the assessments for
that and we see the need for this and a
retained motion I think just puts it off
to no action until at least November
um
however what I'd like to do and propose
for everybody here is that we take we
stop our discussion right here and now
we have not taken any action we have a
motion yes but we haven't taken action
we look at areas that we can put
together a group that's really Dove
wants to delve into this topic and we
use this as the you know the carrier for
you know amending or changing or
tweaking
and moving forward with this bill by
March 16th it's not an early bill so
there's no rush for us to have to today
get this thing done so we can get it
recorded by next you know next week on
on the 16th
I I think you know we we might be acting
in haste here one way the other and and
missing an opportunity
so that that's the the suggestion I have
what where are you on that
representative Miler you agree so if we
agree with that then that's uh and I
said by the end today I'd try to have
some of the subcommittees but I haven't
had time to do that I will do that this
evening and we we have a number of areas
where we have to work on and come back
so uh and and do work by the either at
the end of there's one area couple which
we said by March 16th we just had
another one on that and we have some
others which we we have retained which
we need to put committees together
so with that I think we're done for
today
it's formally recessing it
um 377. yes so at this point in time we
are going to recess this bill and the
way we will address it is when we come
back and want to do this after you know
before prior to March uh 16 it will be
put in a calendar under another exact
session so we'll just bring it up on
that calendar at that time
any comments or suggestions
I'd like to thank representative gagne
and representative Heath Heath for being
here and joining our merry band here
yeah if I may I have to say that it was
very interesting that way out of my
league way out I'm in criminal justice
Transportation Veterans Affairs that's
okay but this when I was listening I
learned a lot actually so it was a maybe
you know maybe I will broaden my
horizons
thank you very much
so with that we are adjourned I thank
you all for coming today and I'll see